when it comes to lifespan there really
are four big elephants in the room
the first is atherosclerosis more people
are going to die from cardiovascular
disease than anything else cancer is
number two then you get into
neurodegenerative diseases and a lot of
this Roots back to metabolic health I
forgot that one right yeah it's almost
the easiest one to forget because
directly it doesn't actually account for
the loss of many lives but once you have
type 2 diabetes your risk of those other
diseases doubles today my guest is Dr
Peter attia he's a former cancer surgeon
and researcher who got his MD from
Stanford he is one of my go-to doctors I
would say the go-to doctor for me for
anything performance or longevity
related I think exercise is the single
most important longevity drug we have
Bar None Peter is both a Visionary as
well as a world-renowned physician who
has dedicated his life to understanding
the science of human health and the Art
of Living a longer more fulfilling life
the occasion for Peter's return to the
show is the publication of its brand new
book outlive the science science and art
of longevity and Peter's basic thesis is
that aging and Longevity are just far
more malleable than we think and with
the right road map we all have the power
to plot a different path for our lives
one that lets us outlive our genes to
make each decade better than the one
before and Peter is generously offered
up 10 signed copies of this
groundbreaking book for us to give away
so if you would like to enter to win a
free copy go to richroll.com subscribe
join our mailing list if you're not
already subscribed and look for an email
on or around April 3rd with further
instructions in today's conversation we
offer a short overview of all of the
subjects covered in the book but in
large part this discourse centers around
the book's Final Chapter which tells the
story of Peter's emotional health during
a dark time and highlights the critical
and and generally underappreciated role
that emotional well-being plays in the
quest for a longer healthier life so
without further Ado this is me and Dr
Peter attia
[Music]
it's great to see you thank you for for
coming back to do the show I've been
looking forward to this for a very long
time uh I woke up this morning to an
interesting text from you about the loss
of voice and saw your Instagram video so
first and foremost like how are you
feeling are you even like up for doing
this yeah I actually feel fine I just
sound worse than I feel but thank you
for agreeing to still sit down yeah of
course you sound a lot better than you
did in the video earlier uh and and you
know before we even get into anything I
think it's curious and interesting that
uh you spent what did you say like seven
hours on calls and zooms yesterday yeah
uh and that is not unrelated to the
final chapter of your book
and you know your podcast is called the
drive you are somebody with a tremendous
amount of drive and so perhaps uh deep
down there's still the the Superhuman
complex or the workaholism gnawing away
at the back of your brain
I suspect so I suspect that uh and
something probably you can relate to
with your own past but I I don't think
addicts ever fully recover I think they
get into recovery but um I will probably
always struggle with workaholism
perfectionism and those things you and
me both there's there's lots to uh lots
to untangle there and that's you know
perhaps where I want to spend a good
amount of of today's episode but before
we even discuss that I did put out I I
re-posted your your little video and put
up a little poll and said you know is
Peter going to be able to do the show
today answer a uh yes Peter always finds
a way B there's no possible way 74
believe in you so we'll roll the dice
and see how this goes
um and I I just want to say that at the
risk of a sort of self-indulgent
monologue at the top here
um forgive me for being a little bit
long-winded but just to kind of set the
stage as I'm reading outlive uh over the
past couple weeks to prepare for today
which you know I adore this book it's a
it's a great service and uh
congratulations on finishing it I think
it's going to help a lot of people
um but in the in my in my kind of uh
semi
unconscious
um
I have a lot of things swimming around
in the back of my mind as you know my
swim coach from Stanford skip Kenny
recently passed away we had a little
discussion about that prior to that dick
jokums who was my coach exactly right
well skip skip is 79. he he died uh you
know the the cause of death had to do
with I guess a hip surgery that he
couldn't quite recover from but he did
have Alzheimer's
um just the other day I had an athlete
in here called Timothy O'Donnell I don't
know if you know him of course but he
you know at age 40 suffered a Widowmaker
in the middle of competing in in a half
Ironman survived finished the race
remarkably
um but that was a very interesting
discussion about you know the nature of
heart disease and and the kind of
strangeness of being such an elite
athlete you know you would think
somebody like that would be immune from
suffering from something like that so
that sense of mortality is kind of
percolating in my Consciousness and
next week I'm going to New York City my
dad is having a a heart procedure a
valve replacement after two failed
attempts at this my mother is suffering
from dementia my grandfather died who
was a champion swimmer died at 54
suddenly from a heart attack I'm 56. as
you know I've got these back issues
which you've been very helpful with
thank you but my point being that that
mortality is very much top of mind for
me uh you know Health span what's truly
important
um
you know is kind of uh really front and
center for me in a way that it hasn't
been previously kind of just you know
very present with that
so I'm really grateful to have you here
today to you know walk us through the
nuts and bolts of Health span extension
um in in a really you know grounded way
you know as I said I think this book is
really important for so many reasons and
not the least of which the vulnerability
that you that you bring to your own
experience and journey with the science
and your own uh lived experience so
thank you for that
um
and uh and and again you know you go
through all of these sort of pillars of
Health span the objective the strategy
the tactics Etc and and the concluding
chapter is all about emotional
intelligence which probably people are
going to find somewhat surprising but I
found to be revelatory I sort of think
you've buried the lead I might have put
that chapter first uh I understand
and there were two views on this Rich
you know the um
it's when I wrote the book
that the the editor uh felt that that
shouldn't be in the book felt that you
know that could be another book if you
want but that doesn't belong here yeah
and then conversely I had a close friend
Hugh Jackman read the book he was one of
the only people who did
and he said the same thing you did he
said this is the opening chapter not the
end
and so there was a tension between those
two views I didn't really know where I
stood and in the end I think the
negotiated truce was really the last
chapter but it'll be in this book
because I don't want to write another
book yeah well for for anybody watching
or listening uh you know please don't
get two-thirds of the way through the
book and not complete it would be my
message to to everyone
um and it as a sort of precursor to
getting into that I do think we should
you know create some context here and
Define some terms
um and you know perhaps let's start I I
do well let me say this
um we did a fantastic podcast uh our
first podcast I don't want to be
duplicated of duplicative of that and
also I know that you're doing a couple
other podcasts and each host has their
own kind of thing that they're going to
be diving into I feel sort of somewhat
uniquely qualified to focus on the
emotional health aspect of it but we
should just canvas you know this a
little bit so we understand what we're
talking about
um so first let's just start with like
how you got interested in this field to
begin with
you mean the field of longevity yes yeah
I mean it really
I think
started when my daughter was born I
think that
just crystallized in me a shift from the
focus on performance where
you know at the time swimming was my
life
prior to that cycling and all other
sports but
um I don't know there was just something
about it which it sounds really cheesy I
think but just
holding that baby I was like
that I didn't even really want if I'm
going to be brutally honest I mean my
wife knows this I
she really wanted to have a kid and I
was indifferent I thought it would kind
of could still you know cramp our style
a bit
um but my indifference and her desire
led to us having a child and then
even the whole time my wife was pregnant
I half jokingly said I don't think I
could like this kid as much as I love
our cat because we had this cat that I
really loved and my wife just rolled her
eyes and then of course the second she's
born like literally there are genes that
just start transcribing and I just look
at this little ball of nothingness and I
think oh my God like I'm obsessed with
her
um
and that um yeah that that was my first
inkling to think about mortality right
that was the first time I thought about
I I want this moment to last forever
even though it won't with this child but
maybe one day I'll have a grandchild
they'll experience this again
[Music]
but you know my training in medicine had
nothing to do with this and frankly I
don't think anybody's does I mean that's
part of the problem I think as I talk
about the book with
this notion of medicine 2.0 right
medicine has come a long way in 150
years it's done amazing things
but um it's a little bit of the what got
you here won't get you there mm-hmm
so
in some ways I think if I have one gift
it's that I can usually identify people
who are really smart
and somehow convince them to Mentor me
and that's sort of what I've spent the
last 12 to 14 years doing is just
figuring out who the best people are in
exercise science in lipidology and
oncology
in endocrinology and
you know just learning from them I mean
and sometimes that would mean like
literally flying out to be in a clinic
with them for a month and just seeing as
many patients as possible and seeing
what they're reading and trying to
understand it and then kind of cobbling
together
[Music]
um
a thesis around what what this means and
and in some ways I think the book is
kind of
the
the culmination of the thought process
and it's much neater today than it was
when I started the book almost seven
years ago
well
the background hum here uh to add like a
layer of nuance is one of you commencing
this journey from a perspective from an
engineer's mind like this is an
engineering problem that I'm going to
solve and and you know your background
is in mathematics on some level you're
you're a Quant guy like I could see a
parallel universe where you're like a
hedge fund guy and you know a character
in billions or something like that like
that's kind of the cloth from which
you're cut you have this early career in
medicine you go into Consulting you
return to medicine with a kind of
renewed Focus or or you know interest in
in this particular field uh with this
idea of medicine 3.0
um uh you know an evolution of the way
we practice medicine uh from a kind of
uh diagnose and prescribed perspective
into one that's more focused on
prevention avoidance delaying uh you
know with a with a very specific focus
on these four horsemen right which are
the four main Killers if we could
um eradicate those delay those Etc uh
we're all going to be extending our
lifespan so talk a little bit about
those four horsemen and why this is kind
of the the locus of the discussion yeah
when it comes to lifespan there really
are four big elephants in the room
um and there's really a fifth that I
think Warren's discussion but it factors
so much into Health span that I usually
talk about it more over there
the first is atherosclerosis and you've
already talked about it personally
um
it doesn't get as much attention as I
think it deserves and I think that's
almost just because we're so used to it
I mean everybody's heard the stats it's
the number one cause of death in men
it's the number one cause of death in
women the leading cause of death in the
United States it's the leading cause of
death worldwide just no matter how you
cut the data more people are going to
die from cardiovascular disease than
anything else
cancer is number two pretty much
consistently in the same boat right for
men for women in the U.S out of the U.S
then you get into neurodegenerative
diseases and in some ways I think these
are kind of some of the scariest
um we certainly have the fewest
treatments for them
and they run the Spectrum from dementia
Alzheimer's disease specifically which
is the most prevalent to Lewy Body
dementia which is kind of a hybrid
between a movement disorder like
Parkinson's and a dementing disease like
Alzheimer's and then of course
Parkinson's disease and then you also
have a whole bunch of dementias that are
not Alzheimer's specifics such as
vascular dementia frontal temporal
dementia things like that
but all of these things are kind of in
some ways shortening our life and in the
case of the latter also reducing the
quality of our life which then leads
into this other idea that I think
doesn't get enough attention in medicine
2.0 which is quality of life and it's
such a glib term
you know the medical definition of
Health span is um
something to the uh to the tune of the
time of life in which you are free of
disability and disease
right but like you and I are just as
free of disability and diseases we were
30 years ago but we're not the same guys
we were 30 years ago there's much more
to it than that and also that doesn't
even capture
the emotional health piece of it in my
mind which I think is
even though it's only 1 17th of this
book in terms of you know content that
simply reflects my expertise in it not
my belief in the importance of it um
so we have these four horsemen and and
the kind of premise here is
um these are the things that are
disabling and and you know destroying
lives more than anything else
um
the biggest barriers to uh longevity
Health span extension and
they take years to to sort of uh
um you know grow and and mature and we
have this period this typical period
what you call marginal decades right
where we're in slow decline as these
diseases progress to the point where
they're typically diagnosed in a in a
medicine 2.0 Paradigm and then treated
with a battery of pharmaceuticals Etc uh
and and your thesis is we need to
replace these marginal decades with what
you call bonus decades
and this goes to
now I understand the graph that is the
the your podcast I never knew what that
graph was that's your podcast uh icon
um your graphic uh now I understand that
and and what was interesting in the book
about you maybe you can elaborate on on
this graph and what it means
um but it's all about kind of pushing
everything out you know a couple decades
later but behind that is is this
um fact that uh when you when you really
look at the science like we really
haven't extended house man
at all in how long 50 years well if you
if you even just talk a lifespan and you
go back
120 years
on paper we've doubled life span right
it's gone from about 40 to about 80.
but if you subtract out the top eight
causes of infectious diseases
it hasn't budget at all that's quite
dispiriting right so one way to look at
that is the glass half full approach is
what an amazing job we've done
um figuring out a way to die of far
fewer infectious diseases right and
that's basically been on the back of two
things right that's antibiotics and
vaccines you know we've eradicated
things like smallpox and polio and
things that were devastating
we now have antibiotics right there's a
good chance you and I would be dead by
now if we lived 120 years ago just on
the basis of some infection
so that's amazing but you know it's sort
of um
there's also you know that you know the
expression of like when the tide goes
out you see who's not wearing their
shorts right well it's kind of like the
tide has gone out and we kind of realize
well wait a minute like we're not
wearing our shorts when it comes to
these other diseases we haven't really
figured out a strategy what what worked
for those diseases what worked for acute
care
doesn't work for chronic diseases where
prevention is what matters now that word
is so deluded it almost has no meaning
because of course everybody on the
surface agrees with prevention well of
course we should have prevention
but
I think what's missing is the time scale
of prevention
you know when you talk about a person
who has a heart attack at 50. that thing
didn't start brewing when they were 40.
it certainly didn't start brewing when
they were 45. that thing was brewing
when they were 20.
and if we'd acted when they were 20 they
wouldn't have had a heart attack at 50.
right there's a uh a graphic in the book
of a young man who was in his 20s right
who who died from a an act of violence
um 23 years old there's a there's a yeah
like a scan of his lad and you can see
the the plaque build up already right
which is not uncommon probably the
typical case and the idea being that yes
we are you know hard at work on these
diseases at a very young age and to the
extent that we can catch these things
sooner or develop better you know
technology and and protocols and and
systems that incentivize these types of
testing you know tests and scans early
on that we could intervene at a point
where we could actually you know
circumvent them
yeah and I think a big part of it just
has to do with
there's an inconsistency sometimes in
medicine
you know causality is one of the most
important things in the universe right
this is if you just think like
metaphysically
causality is such an important concept
and sometimes in medicine it's very hard
to establish
but there are certainly cases where we
know it to be true so we know that
smoking is causally related to cancer
and because of that we have a very clear
strategy for smoking cessation which
means
before you start smoking we're going to
tell you not to smoke the second you
smoke we're gonna try to get you to stop
smoking we don't wait until you've been
smoking for 20 years to say well you've
now accumulated a lifetime risk exposure
to smoking we should do something about
it
some of the words I think when it comes
to smoking we have the idea right
but when it comes to the factors that
are driving say heart disease we're
completely bass awkwards right
we don't act until a person's risk
10-year risk typically is above five
percent and think about that we wait
until your five-year risk your tenure
risk rather for a major adverse cardiac
event is five percent or more to say ah
now it's time to do something about your
lipids
that if we know which lipids are
causally related to this disease
why wouldn't we act immediately
why wouldn't we like what is preventing
that I mean I know that that you know if
you do a blood panel and you have
elevated numbers in in problematic areas
unless those elevated numbers are Beyond
a certain threshold the typical response
is going to be it's not that big of a
deal or there's nothing to see here yeah
which was certainly the response in my
case when I was in my mid-30s and had a
bad family history and even had a speck
of calcium on a calcium score
I think the simplest reason is you don't
have the trial data right so it's very
difficult to do clinical trials
obviously
and prevention trials are the most
difficult of them all because you have
to wait the longest period of time for
an outcome
so there's simply no scenario by which
we're ever going to take a group of 40
year olds who are healthy
take half of them and do you know the
placebo and for other half of them do an
aggressive lipid management and see what
happens over the next 30 years it's an
impossible trial right but at the same
time it's not a binary thing like in
smoking it's it's pretty clear right but
as you kind of eloquently point out when
we get into nutrition uh it becomes you
know unbelievably complicated
um you know obviously you know a doctor
May tell you you should start exercising
or exercise more but beyond that there's
no specificity to that so you spend a
lot of time talking about the different
modalities of exercise Etc so it you
know it becomes it's a it's a Rubik's
cube of you know to the 10th degree
right trying to figure out what the
interventions and protocols should be on
an individuated basis based upon you
know what you know about where a person
is or in the very early in disha of any
one of these Horsemen yeah and I think
it just requires a bit more flexibility
I mean I think that's another
subtle part of what medicine 3.0 is
which is
the term again it's one of these things
the term prevention and preventative
medicine has lost a lot of its meaning
as has the term personalized medicine or
Precision medicine
but on some level what these things mean
are
you have an individual
you will never have a clinical trial
that tells you everything you need to
know about that individual it's simply
impossible clinical trials take a whole
bunch of people they're all
heterogeneous
it squishes down a result into an
average it spits out basically a
homogeneous response
and it says this is evidence-based or
it's not
but within that trial there are lots of
different responses and we kind of have
to understand what that looks like
because no one that I'm going to look at
is the exact average of the input of the
thousands of people that went into that
trial they're going to be one of those
thousands of people so it's we have to
sort of figure out and triangulate like
what does that look like and what's the
implication for them and of course layer
in other things you know you asked a
question
should we be aggressively managing
everybody's lipids early in life it's
also a question of risk appetite that
can come with side effects right I mean
to get the levels to get lipid levels
where they need to be to basically take
heart disease off the table you have to
do it pharmacologically there's no no
change in nutrition one can make no
amount of exercise that's going to move
the needle that much
but that comes with a risk as well and
so you know it always becomes a question
about asymmetry of risk and I just don't
think that those are questions that can
be answered
in a heterogeneous fashion right and and
and in our internet age that's a very
unsatisfying answer right like we want
to know like you know stake your you
know plant your flag in some extreme
position and you know create a you know
create an audience around you know
whatever it is that you're you know what
you know waving that flag around and you
can get a lot of attention and there
might you know I'm sure there's kernels
of Truth and and all of those things but
the truth is is much more complicated
and and sort of masked than that which
makes this difficult and I guess that
that brings up
you know kind of a more meta
conversation around the state of health
span science in general I mean one of
the things I appreciate about
appreciated about the book is that it's
it's so grounded you know and you're not
you're not making any kind of crazy
claims and and I've become kind of
accustomed to and and somewhat annoyed
by allergic to yeah allergic to you know
what this health span conversation has
become which is about moonshots
essentially and it's fun to kind of cast
your gaze into the future and imagine a
world like in that movie Elysium where
people get into pods and it diagnoses
you and cures you immediately and maybe
in some you know at some point we'll who
knows we'll get there but it's certainly
not where we're at right now and so
conversations around you know I'm going
to live to be 180 or 120 and and do all
these sorts of things are are really not
helpful right and and and you've your
your work is very much a departure from
that narrative I think people might go
into this book expecting some something
like that because that's kind of what
the conversation looks like right now so
what is your what is your take on you
know what what that conversation you
know is all about right now and and how
does that differentiate from what you're
trying to say and do you know I don't
think they're mutually exclusive and
going back to kind of what you said
earlier I mean I do sort of think in a
parallel universe I could have imagined
myself being kind of a Quant at a hedge
fund and well given the name of a hedge
fund what are you supposed to be doing
you're supposed to be hedging everything
is a hedge in life you always have a
contingency plan
and
I always say to the people who tell me I
don't need to exercise I don't need to
do this I don't need to do that because
I believe in you know cellular
reprogramming is going to totally Rescue
Me
in 10 years
I say
if you're right that's wonderful if
you're wrong you won't have a chance to
come back to today and undo the damage
so what's the downside in doing
everything in your power to extract as
much value as possible out of the
current you know rudimentary tools like
exercise nutrition sleep Etc
and if you show up in 10 years the worst
thing that's happened if the moonshot is
there
is that you've wasted 10 years taking
care of yourself
contrast that with the alternative
asymmetry which is you screw around for
the next 10 years and there's no
moonshot now the worst thing that
happens is you're on a very quick path
to death right these are these are
completely asymmetric and I think that I
don't know I think that that kind of
thinking has just always been sort of a
part of how I think about stuff so in
some ways I might be the least
interesting least sexy person in this
space because I'm really just trying to
think about it through the lens of what
we know and
look I mean you know what's funny you
mentioned I was on seven Zoom you know
seven hours of Zoom yesterday well two
of it was
talking to scientists about you know a
particular technology around epigenetic
uh reprogramming but in a much more
nuanced way than than gets discussed
sort of in the in the in the Gen pop
so it's something I'm very interested in
but you know and particularly for
example like looking at reprogramming
lymphocytes and T cells to extend immune
function in the elderly because I would
argue
that if you could fix one cell in the
aging body it might be the immune system
because you're going after two diseases
right you're going after all the
Infectious causes of death which for you
and I are nothing but you know actually
by the time you get to 80 and up like
pneumonia does start to play a role but
I think it would also have the biggest
impact on cancer you know why is cancer
growing exponentially as we age
it's probably two things right it's
probably the accumulation of genetic
damage that leads to mutations then
results in cancer cells but I think it's
equally
um that our immune system is weakening
and therefore not fighting back the
cancer so
am I super excited about the idea that
we could genetically reprogram through
an epigenetic rewrite
immune cells and fix that problem
absolutely
if does it happen in our lifetime I have
no idea right but it certainly wouldn't
prevent me from doing everything I can
to maximize my odds of sticking around
long enough right and and on the the
medicine 3.0 you know idea of early
intervention some of the technology
around early testing must excite you as
well because if we if we can develop
Technologies to catch these things at
their Inception that's huge right and
there does seem to be some progress in
that realm yeah I think I think with
cancer
the unfortunate thing is that we are
still relatively Limited in treatments
so I'd say the most exciting thing
that's happened in cancer in the last 20
years
certainly last 10 years has been
immunotherapy
and there's been a kind of what I would
call minor success and a major success
the minor success has been the use of
adoptive cell therapy
so that's when a patient has a tumor and
let's say you can't treat that tumor
with all the traditional means so you
can't cut it out it's too disseminated
not responding to chemotherapy radiation
of course is no longer of any value but
you can Harvest some of that tumor and
within it you can find lymphocytes you
can find their own immune cells that
know how to at least attack and kill the
cancer but you don't have enough of them
you can expand those cancer cells
outside of the body
plus or minus genetically manipulating
them and put them back in and they can
go and if they're insufficient enough
numbers overcome the cancer
that works in a small number of patients
now the Holy Grail there is why can't we
make it work in everybody because in
theory you can always find some
lymphocytes in a patient's tumor that
figured out how to get there and how to
at least kill some of them and the main
reason is they get exhausted when you
expand them so it actually comes down to
the Longevity if you will of the T Cell
so let's bracket that as one problem
that's interesting to solve second thing
in oncology that's been really exciting
is these things called checkpoint
Inhibitors I write about them briefly in
the book these are drugs they basically
take the breaks off the immune system
and so if you have an immune system that
happens to be primed to recognize the
cancer you can take the breaks off it
and it'll go nuts
now the bad news is that most people's
immune system doesn't recognize their
cancer well enough to be affected by
that the good news is if you are in that
camp this works almost every time so
those two things are huge but
collectively
we're talking about a five to eight
percent dent in cancer treatment
so
All Things Considered over the past 50
years that's amazing there's been
nothing that's probably had a bigger
impact
but where's the rest of the Delta going
to come for the next decade for you and
me and for my patients
I think it's going to come from earlier
and earlier detection because the one
thing that is abundantly clear and I go
through several examples in the book
is that stage for stage the fewer cancer
cells you have in your body the better
your body will have a shot at beating a
cancer with even traditional treatments
so even if you're talking about Garden
variety colon cancer being treated with
Garden variety chemotherapy
when you have a billion cells in your
body your odds are way better than if
you have 100 billion cells in your body
because of the number of mutations and
the number of chances that that cancer
has to escape the chemotherapy once you
have an enormous expansion same is true
with breast cancer I mean that's where
we have the best data on this
so liquid biopsies which are probably
what you're referring to are tests that
now allow us to take a couple tubes of
blood
and look for something called cell free
DNA so normally if we take a couple
tubes of blood out of your arm and we're
not looking that hard
we're going to see all your white blood
cells your red blood cells glucose
potassium all these sort of things right
but if you use really really fancy
equipment and high throughput screening
you will notice some DNA that is not
from the cells because most of what is
in your blood is cells and liquid right
it's just plasma cells but there's tiny
tiny tiny fractions like tenth of a
tenth of a percent of fraction of DNA
that is not from the cells in your blood
and these new techniques can not only
identify where they're from hey this is
DNA from a liver cell this is literally
DNA from you know your pancreas or your
lung
they can also predict if there's cancer
in that organ
based on the patterns of methylation on
it
and that could then prompt you to go and
get a more thorough investigation
which means we're going to sort of
hopefully figure these things out a lot
sooner
these things are still in their infancy
we are using these types of scans or
these types of blood tests in concert
with early and you know pretty uh
kind of high-tech MRI scans that are not
sort of traditional scanners
[Music]
and the good news is yeah we're going to
catch things really early the bad news
is you're going to catch a lot of things
that aren't cancer so this gets into
that natural tension of everything you
do has a cost
and usually the financial cost is the
least of your worries the bigger cost is
I can be pretty sure that you don't have
cancer but in the process I'm going to
identify a few things that probably
aren't cancer but warrant follow-up and
that creates Stress and Anxiety and
that's a real cost right and and and
this is something that you're doing with
your patients in in your practice but
I'm imagining uh you know the the
medicine 2.0 Paradigm let's for purposes
of just an example uh you know a 32 year
old male uh listens to this and says
well I'm gonna go get checked out for
everything now I'm inspired by you know
outlive and and Peter's message goes to
his GP and says I want to get tested do
all this stuff what is the response that
that person is is going to get like are
they going to run up against some kind
of barrier that's going to prevent them
from even you know you know being able
to Avail themselves of this kind of
testing probably I mean I had my first
colonoscopy at 40. which at the time was
10 years before any recommendation that
recommendation from 50 has now been
lowered to 45 thankfully I still think
it's too high I really do believe
everyone should have their first
colonoscopy at 40. but when I had my
first one I had to fight like hell to
get it I was paying out of pocket no
insurance company would ever cover it
and so yeah the view is what are you
doing
and again my view comes down to just
risk and asymmetry
a good five percent of people who die of
colon cancer are diagnosed with a colon
cancer that occurs at or before the age
of 40. it's not a huge number but it's
not zero and colon cancer is the third
leading cause of cancer death
so my view is
the upside is that I get to mitigate
that risk the downside is the cost
because I'm paying out of pocket
and the risk of the bowel prep and the
risk of the procedure and the risk of
the sedation if I can quantify all those
risks I can quantify this risk
and on my balance sheet there's no
comparison
um and I mean I think part of it is you
you can say well Peter gosh you know
you're equipped to do that because this
is your profession
and what I hope is that I'm arming
people to do the same sort of
calculation because I think we do have
to do that and we have to be our own
consumers of this stuff right
um but but we have this you know
monolith that is the you know Health
Care system and you know it's Gestalt
towards bankruptcy and the costs that
are you know incurred from treating all
of these chronic ailments you would
think that there would be a financial
incentive to front load patients with
these types of
um uh you know tests and early detection
scenarios to avoid those costs later
down the line but it's so entrenched it
feels like an impossible task to to you
know kind of rewire the system and
create better incentives
yeah it's as you probably know I grew up
in Canada and Canada has a single-payer
healthcare system and there's almost
nothing about Canada's Healthcare that I
think is better than the US is as broken
as the us as is because the Canadian
system is
got more problems but there are two
things that Canada or a single-payer
system does better
the first is it actually provides health
care for all that's we don't need to get
into that discussion here but it's a
tragedy that the number one driver of
personal bankruptcy in the United States
is Health Care related cost that's
unacceptable so nobody should be without
Health Care
but the second thing that a single-payer
system does very well and this is get
this gets to the heart of what you're
asking about rich
is the payer owns the risk for life
so there is an incentive to prevent
right now my health insurance is Aetna
two years ago it was Blue Cross three
years from now it's going to be United
what incentive does Aetna have today to
care about spending a dollar on me when
they are pretty much positive they will
not own my risk in 20 years when the
chickens come to ruse right like that's
the fundamental problem it's the
portability of risk
and I don't I mean I've thought about
this problem so much but
until you fix that problem until there
is true risk ownership between the
patient and the payer and the provider
and that is carried out over the course
of your life there is no incentive for
them to carry any of that risk
yeah I don't know what the solution to
this is but it's not good but I I do
have uh you know hope when I see people
like yourself who have carved out you
know a really successful practice
outside of that Paradigm
um and you know what we're seeing with
functional medicine doctors Etc like
people finding different ways of
practicing medicine that has a higher
priority on the things that you're
talking about
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
the podcast is not the only medium by
which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the Rich Roll
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
Exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday profits and physically interact
with the life-changing ideas contained
with this
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
one of the interesting things when it
comes to the four horsemen is the
overlapping nature of all of these
things and and one thing you talk about
in the book is we we start we tend to
treat these things in isolation as
separate things right like but in a Venn
diagram they're all overlapping in terms
of what's driving them or or causing
them and a lot of this Roots back to
metabolic Health which I feel like is a
a new frontier that finally is getting
the attention it deserves and it's
something that you you know have been
steeped in for a long time so
explain a little bit about what
metabolic health is and how it relates
to you know the onset the onset of these
chronic ailments yeah I'm glad you
brought it up because I kind of got
distracted when you first asked me about
the four horsemen I forgot that one
right yeah it's almost the easiest one
to forget because directly it doesn't
actually account for the loss of many
lives so if you count up the graveyards
with heart disease cancer and neurodegen
diseases that's a lot of bodies if you
go and ask the question how many people
died from type 2 diabetes or fatty liver
disease or insulin resistance it's a
relatively small number of bodies
but the direct contribution of those to
the other three Horsemen is enormous
because once you have type 2 diabetes
your risk of those other diseases
doubles so I think of them as a
Continuum I don't think of them as
discrete diseases you know diabetes has
a very clear diagnostic cutoff when your
hemoglobin A1c exceeds 6.5 percent
which means that your estimated average
blood glucose is now above 140
milligrams per deciliter we put a label
on you you're called type 2 diabetic
but what about when your average blood
glucose is 130 milligrams per deciliter
or 120 milligrams per deciliter I mean
this is a Continuum right so I think of
it as what happens when you're
hyperinsulinemic first earlier signs of
this insulin resistant then you're kind
of get usually the next thing you're
going to start to see is fat
accumulation in places where we're not
supposed to store fat so you know we
were really well designed to store fat
in our Sub-Q space You Know cover up the
six-pack all that stuff that's totally
fine place to have fat
but we were not designed to have fat
around our organs inside our liver
around our heart pancreas and kidneys
those extra you know fat cell places
um fat does really bad things when it
gets in there it's very inflammatory
um and that might be
in fact I wouldn't say it might be I
would say it is the most
underappreciated driver of residual risk
and cardiovascular disease meaning even
once you fix smoking blood pressure and
lipids
you can still have risk of heart disease
just from those fat stores
and
when we think about how many people are
walking around with non-alcoholic fatty
liver disease so as its name suggests
this is fat accumulation in the liver
that is not driven by alcohol which was
historically the thing that we thought
was driving fat in the liver and it was
um
this is devastating both in terms of
liver pathology if left unchecked that
will progress to something called Nash
which ultimately will result in
cirrhosis this is probably the leading
cause of liver transplantation today and
if not today it certainly will be within
a couple of years
so directly there's a huge pathology
there
but indirectly I think it's what it's
doing to these other things is you know
these other horsemen is is a huge
problem
um I don't think we're aggressive enough
in screening these things I talk a lot
about that and talk about how we could
be much more Vigilant and catch these
things earlier
and the challenges you know in some ways
these are the hardest things to fix
because it comes down a lot to exercise
nutrition and sleep
um you have to manage nutrient you have
to be exercising I mean there is simply
no better Elixir for
um metabolic Health fuel partitioning
glucose disposal than being active
and if your sleep is dysregulated it's
almost impossible to overcome it with
enough exercise and nutrition how would
one know if there are
accumulating fat around their organs the
easiest way to get a quick glance is
doing a dexa scan and a good dexa
scanner can estimate what's called
visceral adipose tissue or vat
um
we we use nomograms that basically show
the percentiles by age and sex how much
vat is acceptable so in our practice any
patient that is above the 20th
percentile for visceral adipose tissue
on a dexa scan it's a huge red flag
[Music]
um liver fat is also relatively easy to
identify
um
once it gets bad enough it'll start to
show up in your liver functions
sometimes the doctor will then say well
look we should you know go and do an
ultrasound to take a look
if a person has liver fat the treatment
is usually to try to get them to lose
weight
I think we could be a little bit more
specific than that but that's that's
clearly the best first line and in terms
of of metabolic Health in general you
mentioned you know elevated blood
glucose and what would constitute type 2
diabetes and and perhaps a little bit of
a you know a lower number indicating
being pre-diabetic but there's a whole
range of prevention that we're not
looking at right now to disrupt that you
know train that's that's already been
pulled out of the station yeah diabetes
might be one of the worst examples of
where we just wait too long you know we
really you know we wait until you're at
6.5 before we really bring out the big
guns and
I also think in part it's because
we're optimizing with a different set of
tools
the majority of the treatment the real
treatment for diabetes is drugs like if
we're gonna be honest right I mean we
pay lip service to exercise and
nutrition
but I think most people understandably
like and I don't want to be critical of
the doctor right the doctor's got to see
a patient every 12 minutes if you're
running a clinic
then you're taking care of patients with
type 2 diabetes you've got 12 to 15
minutes with each patient
in 12 to 15 minutes assuming you even
understand enough about exercise
physiology and nutrition
are you going to have an impact or is it
easier to change the prescription and
adjust the multiple medications we have
that are very effective by the way at
you know curbing type 2 diabetes not
really reversing it but keeping it in
check so there's a structural problem
that is just getting in the way of doing
that and if you wanted to fix this
you would have to actually do something
that reverses it and I don't think the
medications are doing that I mean I
think you have to basically change their
nutrition status change the exercise fix
the sleep right despite the
pharmaceutical intervention for a lot of
people it's just a Band-Aid on top of
the causality right and not looking at
the causality is not doing anybody any
good that's right it actually I'm glad
you brought that up it just comes back
to this other issue of cosmology again
right I mean I I believe that and I'm
not alone in believing this right I
don't think this is a I don't think this
is particularly controversial diabetes
is a disease of energy imbalance
right it's a carbohydrate disorder it's
a carbohydrate metabolism disorder that
results from over nutrition um
but part of that over nutrition is
exacerbated by a lack of insulin
sensitivity
so
again you know it's sort of a our body's
a miracle in some ways right
um so if I drew your blood sugar right
now if I checked a blood sugar on you
and it was 100 milligrams per deciliter
that would be a perfectly normal level
that signifies that you have about five
grams of glucose in your entire
circulatory system
five grams is not a lot that's like a
teaspoon of glucose
that's perfectly normal
if I drew your blood sugar and it was
200 milligrams per deciliter
you would be a type 2 diabetic the
implication is you have two teaspoons of
glucose in your circulation
this is not a big difference when you
consider
that your muscles can hold
300 grams of glucose
your liver 150 grams of glucose
so think about this
you could easily get a person who is a
diabetic with 10 grams of glucose in
their bloodstream down to five
if all you could do is get their muscles
to hold more and their liver to hold
back a little bit because your liver is
the one that's kind of percolating it
out there I mean this is a game of
millimeters
and it's not rocket science to tip the
balance in your favor if you take and I
hate the word but if you take a holistic
approach to the organ system right and
and this is a big part of you know the
interventions that you uh that you
pursue with with your patients but a lot
of this begins with getting your
patients to use a continuous glucose
monitor we talked a little bit about
this last time I think so I don't want
to go you know too deep down this Rabbit
Hole uh it seems like at least on the
internet this is controversial which I
don't really understand like any
information should be good information
as long as it's paired with a solid you
know Foundation of of understanding and
education around what these metrics mean
but certainly it provides a window into
what's going on metabolically with the
people that you're working with and I've
you know I've used one myself and it's
been fascinating to see how my body
responds to various foods and in
particular and you go into this in the
book the impact of stress and and sleep
on on how your body metabolizes glucose
yeah absolutely I mean probably the only
subset of patients that I would be very
hesitant to use a continuous glucose
monitoring would be someone with a
history of an eating disorder where you
just put any additional stressor around
food to me that would be probably a
contraindication
but you're right it is it's attracted a
bit of a strange controversy from what I
would describe as
you know a crowd that that probably
wants to view the lens view the world
through a very narrow lens of
evidence-based medicine which is
you know if there is no evidence that a
person without diabetes can improve
their health with this thing it should
never be used
um
there's something to there's something
to be said for that right if we don't at
least consider those things then we'll
be you know the Holden to nonsense all
day long
but we have to remind ourselves that the
absence of evidence isn't the evidence
of absence again closely with that say
so instead in my mind I justify these
things by saying the following look
there is no shortage of data that
demonstrate for non-diabetics that is to
say for people whose hemoglobin A1c is
below 6.5
it's unequivocal that lower blood
glucose is better than higher blood
glucose even within the quote-unquote
normal range in terms of all-cause
mortality
that means if you have someone whose
average blood glucose is 100 milligrams
per deciliter healthy you know that's
that would be a hemoglobin A1c of about
5.1 and someone who's you know blood
average blood glucose is 120 milligrams
per deciliter also clearly not a
diabetic
that person would be about a 5.6 to 5.7
hemoglobin A1c
the all-cause mortality difference is
real so
those data of course are based on
hemoglobin A1c and not CGM but CGM is
allowing you to measure the average
blood glucose which is being imputed by
the A1C and therefore I don't think it's
an enormous leap of logical Faith to say
if the CGM can help you manage to a
better blood glucose
there's potentially a better outcome
there
another criticism that I've heard is
that well you could eat bacon all day
and your blood glucose yeah gaming it or
or you know when you gamification the
whole thing then it's all about like
lowering that that curve which might
drive some unhealthy dietary choice and
I think that's I think that's a totally
valid point
my my sort of
response to that would be well by that
metric we should never use anything that
could be gamed but by that definition
anything became very like that would
mean that body weight is a totally
irrelevant metric which is not true
because you could get if I said
the only thing that is going to
determine the outcome of your life is
your body weight
you could pick up smoking tomorrow and
you know you'd lose weight
but nobody thinks you're improving your
health so you also have to be a rational
actor to do this right you have to
realize that yeah even if I just ate
bacon every meal every day and my blood
glucose went down I'm probably not
improving my health
so
um we we have to be careful we don't
throw the baby out with the bath water
when we start to come up with silly
examples of how people can engineer and
you know Goof Off with the game right
um
I opened this by saying we were going to
go right into emotional health but I'm
glad that we've talked about the things
that we we have talked about
um and you know before we launch into
that like like let's just say within
this strategy of avoiding preventing
delaying minimizing The Four Horsemen
um you have these uh four tactics
basically which involve exercise
which your thesis being that this is the
most important driver of healthspan
extension of anything that you could do
and lifespan and lifespan you have
nutrition you have sleep and then you
have emotional intelligence but and the
one I omit by the way just because it
would have been another book is all of
the medical management you know it's
sort of like right that's what that was
my butt like there's nothing in this
book about pharmacology supplements and
that seems to be the thing that people
want to talk about the most right like
what is the supplement the NAD the nmn
and like all that kind of stuff right
like this is not part of anything that
you're yeah there's I mean I do talk
about a couple of drugs talk about
rapamycin there's a whole chapter on
that talk about that actually I didn't
know that that whole story about Easter
Island yeah it's wow cool
um I talk about lipid lowering drugs I
talk
um and that's about it you're right I
don't really go deep into the other
stuff the initial plan
was there was going to be an appendix in
this book that was going to deal with
just the what I thought were the 20 most
relevant drugs and supplements
as I started to write said appendix I
realized it was going to add 200 pages
to the book um
because I couldn't do I couldn't do
justice to each one of those in under
about 10 pages
and so that idea quickly got sort of
shut out right
um so the good news is I write
extensively about those topics elsewhere
I podcast about those topics elsewhere
um
and I just felt that you know
this was the most interesting stuff to
be writing about because it was the
stuff that was not getting enough
attention elsewhere
this book almost never happened also
like in the the epilogue or in the
acknowledgments you basically were like
I I worked on this for a long time I
missed my deadline for a year the
publisher back you know like yeah why
was this so difficult for you to
complete
um I think they're I think there were
two forces um
I think the first is
I don't know did you experience this
when you were writing your book I mean
as a perfectionist did you just feel
like I can't put this thing out there
because it's not 100 percent
a million times yes you know yeah like
that's yeah this goes in okay good
elaborate like this is we're getting
into this stuff I really want to talk
about with you yeah yeah so there was
the it's not quite good enough yet it's
not quite good enough yet it's not quite
good enough yet
I think there was a much deeper problem
going on which is I was
early on by
2008 so I started the book in 2016.
17 is kind of a blur my life is falling
apart as the book describes
18 I'm trying to pick up the pieces of
it
and by 19 I'm I'm back to kind of
writing the publisher is furious at me
at this point this is a different
publisher by the way so penguin is my
current publisher uh the other publisher
I won't name but it's one of the other
big five
they've kind of had it with me at this
point
um
but at this time I know I got I gotta I
can't just ignore this emotional health
piece like I gotta be able to write
about this because it's such an
important part of Health span
and health span matters as much as
lifespan
so on the one hand I feel conflicted
because I want to write about it and on
the other hand I feel like I can't write
about it because
I don't have my act together weren't
well enough I wasn't well enough yeah
comment on it so
I was sort of spiraling out of control
in early 2020. when
um
basically the publisher just kind of
shot me an ultimatum I remember I was
filming Limitless actually I was in uh
Norway so I was actually trying to fly
back from normalizing like I remember
this very well in this dark
awful hotel in a place I'd never seen
before because the flight got canceled
and I got stranded in some small place
and I get this really nasty email from
the publisher very threatening if you
don't deliver this thing by such and
such a date like we're going to take
action blah blah blah wow and I just I
just called my CEO and said wire them
the money tomorrow tomorrow and tell
them to [__] off
um
and so that was the end of that
it wasn't that long ago
yeah three years ago yeah
and then the book basically
I just said I don't want to write this
anymore I'm done with this
and um and then the events of 2020
unfolded
and
fast forward uh
to late 2020
.
um I I was talking to Michael Ovitz
who's a close friend and
I don't know why it came up I don't know
why the manuscript came up this part I
don't remember I think we were talking
about his book which I had maybe just
read
and I was like Michael I can't believe
it took me this long to read your book I
loved it but blah blah blah
and he was like send me your send me the
manuscript and I was like oh it's it's
not that good it's like just send it to
me anyway so I did and he read it and
then he's the one that said no no you
got to finish this thing and he said if
you can get me something within he said
try to get me something within like six
weeks that I can send to my friend at
penguin um and that's what kind of
resurrected the whole surface the whole
thing yeah
um when you were here the first time
after we wrapped the podcast you shared
with me a little bit about you know your
your personal journey I knew nothing
about that I had no idea
um and then in reading this final
chapter of the book like it's really
powerful you you you know you really
laid it out with quite a bit of
vulnerability and I think it's really
important and you recognize the
importance of this basically the emote
the emotional health piece being like
the most important thing because if you
don't have your act together with this
what is the point in extending your
health span like what like Esther perel
says to you like you know why do you
want to live longer like when you're so
miserable which
sets in motion uh you know this journey
towards recovery so talk a little bit
about what was going on with you leading
up to this realization
but I think there were really two big
things that were obviously related but
temporally distinct
um
so I think by um by 2016 2017
you know I was probably working
I mean I was working really hard I was
traveling constantly my wife was
pregnant with our third child
I was nowhere to be found I mean my two
kids that were at the time my daughter
and my son didn't actually think I lived
at home
they actually thought I lived in New
York or San Francisco or where the hell
I was traveling
you know I had offices in two different
places and all this kind of stuff
um but I think it's worse than that
right like I I wish I could just say oh
it's just that I was like a super
hard-working father who was like just
you know working you know working really
hard to make a lot of money for his
family no I think it was also that I was
getting
more and more detached you know and more
and more
um just sort of
selfish you know I think naturally I'm a
very selfish person and I think that
selfishness was just growing and growing
and growing and you know the event that
comes to a head that I write about is um
after our youngest son is born in in
June of 2017.
I barely make it home for his birth I
don't think I write about that but I I
was in New York when my wife went into
labor she was annoyed that I even went
to New York the week she was due but I
was like yeah don't worry I'll make it
back of course I barely make it back
so I get to the hospital maybe an hour
before he's born and then two days later
I'm back on the road
and
about five weeks later I'm in New York
um a friend of mine from Boston is in
town we're getting ready to go out
and I get a call from her and she says
you know her youngest son
um just had a cardiac arrest I'm in the
ambulance with him we're heading to you
know UCSD radies
he's an infant he's he's five weeks old
yeah and he you know uh we still did
this day don't really know what happened
he probably just had some awful
vasovagal insult but you know
by some miracle it happened during the
day the nanny saw him
roll his eyes back and turn blue and
luckily my wife is a nurse practitioner
you know she's done critical care of her
whole life so
just did CPR and I'm like put them on
the floor you know sternum compressions
the whole thing while the nanny calls
the paramedics four or five minutes
later they're there just as he's coming
back
um and for reasons that you know I can
finally say this without breaking down
but for reasons I'll never understand I
just didn't get on a plane to go home
I was just so detached I literally just
treated like it was a patient
I was like okay call me when you get to
the ICU
and then for the next like five days I
just did a check-in with the doctors
every day and
I didn't drag myself home until 10 days
later 10 10 days later you came home
yeah
and it's just it was it was just so
blind to what an [__] I had become
it's so hard to I mean I don't know you
that well but it's hard to Fathom that
you would make that choice uh you know
understanding a little bit about you
know what you know kind of your your
your makeup uh you know I can I can see
how this would come to be but it's you
know it it's shocking to hear that uh
but I think it's really courageous for
you to admit that not just you know in a
podcast but you know in in in the book
as a you know a way of Illuminating like
the depths of like how far gone you were
in terms of your emotional health at the
time
it was very hard to write that
um it was
[Music]
um
and and honestly it's something I my
wife's only read to this day my wife's
only read one chapter of that book
that's she hasn't read the book yet you
know because it's not out yet but I did
ask her to read that chapter I wouldn't
have written that chapter without her
blessing
um because I know that that's something
my kids are going to read one day
and like my son will read that one day
you know he's five today but he's gonna
he's gonna read that one day and know
that his dad didn't come home and it's
so funny he
he says I don't know how he knows this
but he must have heard us saying this
but
he always says mommy saved me
um and lately he's been saying
daddy did you save me too
and I say no I didn't Arie I didn't save
you let me saved you
daddy wasn't there why weren't you there
like he's he's starting to ask these
questions
um
and so you're you're the Healer this is
your identity yeah
so so there will be a reckoning for this
I mean there will be there's no question
so as the summer of 2017 bled into the
fall of 2017 I was spiraling out of
control like I mean there's this
I don't know what was driving all of
this but I mean
I almost got into a fight in a parking
lot with someone
um and and this is like
I mean this was more than just a
shouting match like I was going to kill
someone in a parking lot over nothing
literally
some guy left a note on my car you know
a chirping note at my car and I was like
oh really
I mean so
around this time Paul Conte who you know
yeah is one of my closest friends uh we
were we met the first day of med school
and immediately connected over our love
for ayurton Senna who my youngest is
actually named after
um
and Paul and I shared an office in New
York so we saw each other all the time
and
he just said I I think you need to go
somewhere I think you need to go
somewhere for
for their you know for like Residential
Care
um
and I was just completely reluctant to
do this I mean he talked about you need
to go into a TR you know this he was
talking about this place called the
bridge to recovery which is for trauma
and I was like
I mean it just doesn't make any sense
dude like what are you talking about and
he's like
he goes you gotta you gotta trust me
like you live like a trauma victim
everything about you is a response to
trauma and I don't know what it is but
you you know he just basically said in a
non-condescending way you kind of just
kind of trust me
and so ultimately I did go there I went
there at the end of 2017 for two weeks
had anybody else told you that you would
not have listened
that's correct right yeah
um the stuff in the book about about uh
the bridge from my perspective as
somebody who's been in treatment yeah
yeah I want to hear your thoughts pure
comedy like just you can see textbook
yeah like hilarious like your resistance
uh just refusing to participate you know
unable to share even the remotest you
know kind of emotional response
completely detached from you know any of
any any ability to connect with let
alone articulate like what was going on
inside of you
um it's pretty funny it's good stuff and
to the point where this goes on I can't
remember whether it was the first
Treatment Center or the second one where
uh the other impatients are like is this
guy a serial killer like he's just
sitting there silently he won't talk
like what's going on with this guy yeah
I mean at some point they gave me a
piece of paper that had
all the different types of emotions and
they were like just see which one of
these you are like I know you say it's
anger but there must be something
besides anger like is it anger because
of hurt is it anger because of
embarrassment is it anger like they were
really trying to help me expand my
vocabulary because I sort of showed up
as a monosyllabic
idiot right
um so
you know the two weeks I spent at the
bridge was
absolutely the beginning of the change
but I
I think
incorrectly left after two weeks and and
everybody sort of felt I really needed
to be there for at least six weeks
because it's really designed as a bigger
program
the first two weeks is really just to
uncover what the heck is going on
but you don't get handed any of the
skills to go about fixing it mm-hmm
so even when I came back
um I wasn't really in a position to kind
of fix anything sure yeah it's
interesting like you leave AMA right
like the patient you know the the the
the smart doctor guy is a terrible
patient uh you're somebody who who
resides in your mind you you pride
yourself on your intellect you're a very
smart guy these are people that that uh
you know are very resistant to this type
of help right like I'm okay I understand
this intellectually I get it like I'm
gonna now solve this problem with my
brain not understanding that it is that
brain that created the problem to begin
with and the journey towards recovery
involves disentangling all of that
letting go and allowing people in to
help you but you're somebody who who is
you know basically fueled by self-will
and your own sort of independent way of
doing things outside of any external
inputs
and you know the interesting thing is I
think when I left the bridge I was
definitely cracked open
um and I think I did
great things when I got out in terms of
like it's not like I didn't you know do
therapy and Esther introduced me a guy
named Terry real who was amazing
um but there was also certain things I
missed that I think you only get in
residential care and one of the things
was every night at the bridge you went
to a 12-step meeting in town
so every single night imagine that for
14 straight nights you were at a 12-step
meeting and they don't care which
12-step meeting it is so I was doing a a
essay like n a it didn't matter yeah but
are you just like moving back well I
mean I no I initially of course I was
initially I was like
why am I here I don't even have my phone
like what am I doing here like
but I'll tell you by the time I started
to crack open I was
I was really moved by this and I
remember when I got back to San Diego
thinking I wish I could go to a 12-step
meeting even though I'm not an alcoholic
like I want to listen to what they're
saying like I want to hear that there's
someone else who's struggling with
something
[Music]
um
and I think that was a missed
opportunity yeah so a seed is planted
you've got Paul you've got some
introduction to the notion that trauma
plays a role you are resistant to the
idea of of of being an addict in any way
like I'm not an addict like I yeah I
almost got in a fight and like uh yeah I
realize like I work too hard and I'm not
present with my family but does that
really put me in the category of these
other people like you're struggling with
your ability to connect and and relate
to
um you know what is being presented to
you
and I think
I started to fix I did
I guess it was probably by about the
summer of 2018
I really did
start to make some really big
improvements with my my wife and I
really started to heal
from from all of that that hurt
now still working way too hard
we're still traveling like a dog
um
and I don't write about this in the book
but this goes on for another year until
November of 2019 I have
probably the closest I've ever had to a
nervous breakdown at the time
it was actually in Austin so this is why
I still live in San Diego
you know every year I go out to watch
Formula One mm-hmm
and uh so sure enough I go out to Austin
to see coda
and
um
I had an amazing lead up to it hosted a
bunch of podcasts there were some people
I wanted to interview there
um
the night the morning of the race
I wake up
and I just have a total anxiety attack
which I've never had in my life and I
decide I can't go to the race
so I just call an Uber go to the airport
and go home I miss the race
and I get home and my wife thinks it's
really weird
and she assumes it's well
maybe he's just feeling like really
burnt out and just needs to be with us
more
um but something was definitely broken
and the next day we had our team was in
town we were supposed to be making a
bunch of content videos
and I just completely flipped out I was
at the Whiteboard literally trying to
make the first one and I made a mistake
and I flipped out like I was like I'm
done I'm done we're done like this whole
thing's over this was 2020 2019. oh this
is this is before the stuff you talk
about in the book okay wow
and
and then I spiraled into a very deep
hole of
like
I mean
very significant thoughts of self-harm
very
very desperate so so bad that Paul
actually flew down to San Diego
and
um
we we hold up in a hotel for a day and
Paul's diagnosis at that time was
crystal clear which is
you you are so angry at yourself for how
much you punish yourself
that you're you're kind of turning your
anger inward now at the guy who's been
whipping you like there's a guy inside
who whips you and you are now so angry
at him that you want to hurt him and
he's like you have got to stop this
and I was like
okay okay I'll start taking you know and
I and I again I just did this stupid
thing of like I'll do a little bit less
I'll do a little bit less I'll do a
little bit less
um
and I limped along until I didn't
the elevator's going down
you got a couple opportunities to step
off but you needed a little bit more
pain yeah so 2020 it really all comes to
a head
yeah and I think I would have been able
to limp along for another couple of
years had it not been sort of the acute
crisis of covid
and
and who knows maybe maybe it would have
happened regardless but
but it all kind of came to a head one
day in a really scary way
and um it's really weird that we're
talking about all this because I I I
just think people are gonna I still to
this day when I talk about this stuff
well I've never really talked about this
publicly so I there's a part of me that
worries that you know
Society I'm just not sure I want people
to know about but
um
so on this particular Wednesday
in April of 2020. started like any other
day right so wake up and it wasn't like
any other day because this was you know
slightly you know this is during covid
so it was you know different hours I
sort of scheduled a day where I would do
my work early early in the morning
because we had an East Coast team so
we'd start calls at six in the morning
Etc
a lot of my rituals are kind of gone a
lot of the sort of things I do for
self-help are being thrown out the
window
but I do I always you know do something
for pleasure before I work out so I'm
either gonna go and shoot my bow and
arrow or go and get in my simulator and
drive and then exercise and then you
know by 10 o'clock and get back to work
so I got to shoot my bow and arrow
and I'm really shooting poorly
um now archery is a pretty objective
thing like there's x's and you're trying
to hit them
and I'm
for me I'm I'm off
and I am so pissed off
that I take these carbon arrows and I
start snapping them on my thigh
now
these things leave welts on your legs
that last for a week when you break them
that's how much it hurts and I couldn't
stop breaking them on my leg
every one of them
and then I decide in my Infinite Wisdom
that the best thing I could do then is
go and get in the simulator and drive
right
because ramp this up another well
because you know it's like look I didn't
get the self-validation doing this thing
I'm gonna go find another way to get
self-validation so I go and get in the
simulator
get into the hardest car
on the hardest circuit
and sure enough
I'm spinning she can't keep the car in
control
amazingly I don't break the simulator
and then I decide okay I'm gonna go and
work out
and for the first time in my life I'm
actually too upset to work out like I
can't I don't have the motor control to
lift weights
which is very It just strikes me as an
impossible scenario
the rest of that morning spirals out of
control but culminates with me
absolutely losing my mind
and
taking a table in our living room and
throwing it across the living room
um wow at which point my wife comes
running in thinking that the house has
been broken into
and the rest of it is a bit of a blur
her at first trying to console me
but then quickly realizing it's way too
dangerous to be near me
um
and then just telling me to get out
I ended up in a motel
um
and didn't eat or drink anything for 3
I guess three days
was on the phone phone with Paul Esther
Terry
convincing them that I I was ready to go
home and all of them saying absolutely
not like if you go home we're going to
call the police
wow like there's only one thing that
left free to do you you have to go to
this place called PCS psychological
counseling service
um which is this place in Phoenix
and of course I just fought with them
for hours I was like I can't do it I
can't do it
and they're like you're
you're missing the plea you're acting
like we're giving you a choice because
don't you know who I think I am and I'm
so busy and I have all these
responsibilities I can't do it because
I'm too scared to do it I mean obviously
there's there's probably a bit about
that but but it's all being it's all
being here I'll tell you what the fear
was rich truthfully the fear was I'm not
fixable so why are we [__] around
with this and that's really the core of
the whole thing yeah right like that's
what that's what starts to to get
revealed like what is behind this this
this rage what is the relationship
between that rage and Trauma and your
relationship not only with your past but
but with yourself right
yeah so I think the surface fear is it's
impossible for me to go away for a week
and they said
it could be one it could be two it could
be three that's going to be decided by
them but I said even a week is
impossible because I like I can't go off
the grid like when you're at these
places as I'm sure you know you don't
have a phone sure you're not doing
anything like you're in therapy 13 hours
a day seven days a week
group therapy individual therapy I mean
it's it's the most exhausting thing you
can do
but you're absolutely right underneath
it was the Deep the much deeper fear
which is
I'm that guy
I'm that guy who has to go into rehab
every three years and never gets fixed
just euthanize me like why are we why
are we doing this nonsense right and it
seems like and correct me if I'm wrong
there's this this tension or or
dichotomy of of kind of holding two
contradictory perspectives on yourself
on the one hand
uh you know I'm look at me I'm so
successful I have all these
responsibilities from the outside
looking in it appears that everything is
together uh and I know how to solve this
better than anyone because I'm me right
and on the other hand I'm the worst
piece of [__] in the world I should just
die I am broken it's irreparable like
who cares why even try and and and and
you're absolutely correct and then on
top of that there's the shame of
God forbid anybody actually think I'm
special if they could only see how
horrible I am right right
and the fear that at least publicly
anyone would know that you're that you
have some fallibility especially so deep
right it's one thing to be like
oh I eat too much chocolate or something
like that but this is this this this to
me
was like a rot to the core of like who I
was right this was this was not just a
quirk of Personality or a or a you know
oh I struggled with smoking or something
no no this struck me as like
a fundament like this was the to me the
lowest possible
you know set of character traits one
could have
which also creates the best uh place to
begin this kind of work right like that
that you know you hit bottom
yeah so hopefully that creates a space
of willingness to entertain a new way
yes it's sad to say I had to hit rock
bottom and of course
you know here we are three years later
my life is completely different
uh in all ways
infinitely better
people you know sometimes people say to
me
there's a question you think you can ask
anybody right like if you could go back
and talk to the 20 year old version of
you what would you tell them what would
you do different
on the one hand I wish I could say
figure this stuff out 30 years sooner
buddy but You're Gonna Save everybody
including yourself but more importantly
people you love you're gonna save them
so much pain
on the other hand I think
I don't know if I could have figured
this out unless I was on the bot in the
basement right like I just I think
at least for me
I needed to be in so much pain
to actually do this thing to go through
this stuff I mean do you think about
that you and me both buddy you know I
mean when you present emotional health
as this core pillar in hellspan uh
on the on the kind of subject of early
intervention like all of this is about
like how do we
catch these things diagnose them and
start treating them way earlier on than
we historically have been doing the
tricky thing with emotional health is it
does require willingness so you could
you could you know if somebody came up
to you when you were 28 or 24 or 30 or
whatever and tried to intervene and get
you to understand that this is important
there's no way that you would have
been game to you know dive into this
right so it's it's a lot more difficult
but perhaps had that intervention
occurred when you were eight years old
or there were modalities in place to you
know help you make sense of confusing
things you know in your in your
childhood during that period of time it
could have created a different
trajectory
yeah
you know for me the the sign that this
was really I was ready to go through it
was
the most important thing I had to let go
of was
whatever changes I'm about to make will
result in me being less effective in my
professional life that's the big one
yeah that's the big one and that gets to
the root of your sense of self and the
incident you know workaholism that's a
manifestation of that
um of that sense of that unhealthy sense
of self like the facts of your
experience as they say in the parlance
of recovery like the facts of your
experience are very different from mine
but the emotional landscape is so
relatable to me like there's a lot of
overlap like we've you know manifested
our our disorders in different ways but
it's so similar to me in in so many ways
and and and there is that thing of uh of
of of of nurturing that dysfunction
under the illusion or the belief that
that is the the engine from which you've
been able to create a pretty great life
and if you're to go and if you're if
you're to dismantle that then What
Becomes of you like you aren't going to
be able to do the thing that you that
you do that has distinguished you
um and and crafted this identity and
sense of self
yeah and all the success everything yeah
and then the funny thing is
Maybe by some Metric I'm less successful
and less driven today than I would be
had I stayed on that path
but
the opportunity cost of that was too
great and I'm actually really
comfortable with that one of the things
that I never thought could go away I
talk about this in the book is the whole
Bobby Knight thing
this was one of the most important
realizations I ever had when I was at
PCS
which is what my inner monologue sounded
like
and it sounds
well it's a little hard to believe I
wasn't aware of it given that it wasn't
just an inner monologue it was actually
also an outer monologue
I would constantly say things to myself
out loud whenever I made mistakes the
self-talk was not just in my head it was
it was verbal it would come out and it
was awful right it was
the re the reason I called that Bobby
Knight is that's that's who it was
modeled after right it was
coach Knight is going to strangle you if
you make a mistake and it was anything
right it didn't matter if I screwed up
making dinner
if I screwed up a shot if I screwed up
anything if I was late to a call
I remember one morning I woke up and
there was a call on my calendar at six
that I had forgot about and I when I
woke up I did a whole bunch of other
things before and I missed the call
instead of just emailing the person and
saying hey I'm really sorry I mean I
must have beat myself up about that for
a day uh-huh
and
this exercise that they had me do there
was one of the most powerful things I've
ever done and when they suggested it I
thought
it seems kind of dumb
there's no way that's going to work
and they were like
every single day
two or three times something is going to
happen that's going to prompt you to
want to scream at yourself
take out your phone
and record a message
but look into the eyes of your best
friend and pretend that they made that
mistake what would you say to them
I mean the first few times I did this I
was in tears
because it was such a shift of how kind
I would speak to that person
you know hey Peter I know it's
frustrating you you just
you know didn't have a good drive today
but you know I think I think there's a
lot on your mind today and and you know
you did okay but you know you got to
watch the Apex going into this corner
and like I literally I was like talking
like I was a kind coach yeah
and there was an accountability where
every one of those I would send to my
therapist
so
Katie Powell would get every one of
those as a text message should get like
two or three of these voice messages a
day for four months
and it only took about four months
for that to go away
that is really amazing to me yeah that's
powerful think of how old I am and think
of how many years I had this ingrained
pattern of screaming at myself and I
mean I don't even want to repeat the
stuff I say because it's so vile but
like it's not like you idiot no it's
much harsher than that
and in just four months of being mindful
of this every single day
I don't even remember I it's so hard for
me to remember Bobby's voice
that's a uh a powerful Testament uh
neuroplasticity that you could rewire
that because that is so deeply ingrained
that's something that that I share this
inability to extend compassion to myself
that is second nature to extend to
another human being
um I I don't know if I don't think you
know this but
um before Christmas I
I went up and spent a week at at Paul
Conte's Clinic no doing some trauma work
and and family of origin work and it was
revelatory uh for for many many reasons
like I'm I'm just so grateful that I was
able to have that experience and I
learned a ton but but perhaps the
biggest Revelation that came out of that
was this very thing of my inability to
to exercise self-compassion like the
negative self-talk and the standard to
which I hold myself is far beyond
anything that I would expect of anybody
else to the point of just you know utter
cruelty and the extent to which this not
only runs deep but infects like
everything that I do to my detriment so
first just I mean obviously I've kind of
always known this but like really trying
to understand that and then and then you
know creating that that lattice work to
understand how that relates to Childhood
trauma and then beginning the process of
of undoing it like has been you know has
been extraordinary despite like all the
years that I've been in recovery like
all the year everything that I've done
uh I still have had
some of this sort of uh repressed rage
that would come out periodically not to
the extent that it that it did with you
but enough where my wife would be like
you really need to figure out like why
you're behaving this way or why this
stuff kind of comes up and I sort of
delayed it
and I would rationalize like well I'm
doing all these other things like what
else do I need to do but there was this
thing sitting there like just waiting
like a ticking Time Bomb
um that that needed to be looked at and
the fact that I you know took a week to
you know just begin that process has
been extraordinary so I'm curious in
your case
you know what did you discover in terms
of that that Rage which I think you know
probably a lot of people can relate to
like why do I get angry at this thing or
that thing like how did that how did how
does that connect to your past and how
did you begin to like make sense of that
so that you could untangle it you know I
think um as you obviously learned with
Paul I mean I think there are lots of
different types of traumas there were
big treats Big T and Little T traumas
right there are
um
sometimes it's easy to focus on the Big
T ones and
I've had a big T trauma
um couple I think
but what I think I learned at PCS was
I've probably been more undone by the
little T traumas it's probably more some
of the neglect
in the sense of
I mean truthfully I think the single
most important Insight is that
I have NE I had never until I got there
and and it this remember how they said
you know you might be there for a week
two three I was there for three weeks
like I was like one of the five percent
of people that was there for 21 days
I didn't have my breakthrough there
until the 19th day I mean two weeks in I
thought I was better
I was ready to go home the next day and
Paul called me and said look
we've all pow out you know me Esther
Terry Katie like the whole team has
powered with their team and we think you
were not quite there there's one thing
you're not willing to let go of
and I was like are you freaking kidding
me what
and they're like you haven't really
accepted the fact
that
like the child in you was really hurt by
these things and these adaptations
they
they're not in the child's best interest
anymore like
your response these things that you did
as a kid are not normal childhood
behaviors if you saw your kid doing
these things you would be devastated by
how sad it is and by the loss of their
innocence and by the loss of their
childhood
and in other words sorry to interrupt
but in other words the story that you
had been telling yourself was these
things happened but ultimately they made
me who I am and they gave me this engine
and propelled me to do all of these
other things and yeah it wasn't great
but like I've made peace with it that's
right it was these things were really
bad and I get it and I would never want
my kids to endure these things but you
have to understand like they've been way
more net positive than negative
especially now that we've figured out
what these negative things are I have
coping skills for them and they were
saying no no no no you got to go to
Quant perspective you got to go back and
realize like
this little boy that never wanted to
celebrate a birthday
like that this little boy that wanted
his daddy to be there and he wasn't like
those things aren't okay
and
that that kind of took me down into an
emotional Free Fall that was I think the
final layer of excuses
because
I think you can probably relate to this
but
one of the ways I had rationalized my
bad behavior for so long
was
my kids aren't going to suffer what I
suffered
and I think that addicts can sometimes
do that they can sort of say like
you know well
but you know I'm making this up this
wasn't the case in my case you know my
dad used to beat me with a belt every
single day and look I'm not beating my
kid with a belt every single day so it's
fine meanwhile give me a medal yeah and
and
I think that that
was also a very important part of my
motivation was when I finally realized
how much I was hurting my kids
it was
they weren't actually experiencing the
traumas I experienced
but I was they were experiencing a whole
bunch of new ones
and the kids of Alcoholics don't always
go on to become alcoholics right yeah
but that doesn't mean that trauma isn't
intergenerational it really is it
weasels its way down
um
and
that that that realization coupled with
being at Rock Bottom was sort of like
you know what I'm gonna stop it I I
don't want I don't want this going to my
kids
yeah there's a couple uh quotes from
from the book that kind of really hammer
on that point
um one of which is this idea that that
children take on the shame of those
around them like understanding that even
if on paper you feel like you're you're
you're the dutiful dad and you're
protecting them Etc that all of this
emotional dis ease you know percolates
into their
conscious awareness and and impacts them
and their behavior later in life and
um the other one being uh
you know this idea of covert male
depression and this this this statistic
that 90 of male rage is helplessness
masquerading as frustration
like that's a Zinger it it speaks to me
and you know look that was something
Terry told me one day in in a therapy
session
um
and I was talking about it with Esther
recently or not recently like recently
after that or shortly after that and she
said I want you to write that down on a
Post-It and stick it on your monitor I
mean it's
and it's it's so true
how often do I find myself even today
getting angry about something
and if I just stop and think about it
I'm helpless I feel helpless I feel
powerless yeah and and we're just I mean
I again I think for men in particular
it's very difficult to articulate that
and accept that and it's so much easier
to just channel that helplessness into
some form of anger
or workaholism or exercise addiction or
any number of of modalities that you
know basically Society isn't going to
frown on too hard and you can get away
with and and and may very well even make
you successful which makes it so
pernicious
all right yeah that is that is the
that's the irony right is a lot of the
people that I met in both the bridge and
PCs
had all of these socially unacceptable
addictions
and
I think by the end of it I came to
realize we're pretty much all the same
there's no difference between yeah you
go on that Journey from sitting there
just identifying all the differences why
you're not like any of these people
until finally you realize it's kind of
all the same totally one of the thoughts
I had when I left was
would we be better off I wonder what you
think about this rich
right now when you look at sort of
recovery programs they're often
organized around the end State what's
the addiction so if you're if your
weakness is alcohol drugs sex gambling
Etc workahol isn't perfection like
we're going to organize those people
together
I almost wonder if we could organize it
more by root cause like if your shame is
the result of this type of wound and
that drives you to do this this or this
like you should spend time with these
people too it's almost like a matrix
approach where we think about what the
you know end state is but what the root
causes were as well yeah and there might
be some benefit in both of that because
that's what I found really
I found really beautiful actually was
getting to know
so many other people through these
experiences at both the bridge and these
are people I'm still in touch with like
we still have a text thread this is like
five and a half years ago and everyone's
story is different but boy what was the
expression like history never repeats
itself but it short rhymes like
there are some really common patterns
here and I think everybody sort of feels
alone sometimes I think that it really
is uh you know to your to your question
of of
um you know root cause versus
manifestation uh addiction the addiction
is the adaptation that is the you know
humans attempt to try to cope with the
root cause and it works for a long
period of time or you wouldn't do it and
then it stops working right and then it
creates chaos and havoc and and all the
rest but my the kind of drum that I've
been beating is is really that it is all
the same thing and you can quibble
around you know differences in root
causes this trauma that trauma but you
know Paul or Gabor mate or Esther would
probably agree that so much of it is so
deeply rooted in some that happened in
your childhood whether it's a big T or a
series of little T's Etc
um but then you're you're correct like
is it alcoholism heroin addiction
gambling whatever to me it doesn't
matter like it's all the same thing and
addiction lives on this huge spectrum
and I think almost anybody is going to
be able to identify themselves if
they're really being honest with
themselves if they do a you know
rigorous inventory they're going to see
that that you know they're somewhere on
that Spectrum maybe they just scroll a
little bit too much on their phone or
they keep getting in involved with the
same kind of bad relationship or what
have you it it shows up in you know
innumerable ways but ultimately it is
the same sort of you know compulsive
behavior that drives negative outcomes
that you perpetuate and feel you know uh
unable to control
that ultimately escalates
right yeah so whether it's a substance a
behavior what have you you know our our
outward manifestations are different
although there's some overlap in the
kind of workaholism and the
perfectionist uh realm but it really is
the same thing and and I think that
we need to broaden the conversation
around the nature of this condition and
you know create a bigger welcome mat for
people to engage with it because I think
this sort of traditional sort of secrecy
around or the shame that surrounds it
prevents healing for a broader
population of people like I I may have
gone into 12-step step earlier had I
known a little bit more about it or
hadn't been you know it was so
mysterious that I had a whole set of
ideas about what it was and what it
wasn't that maybe kept me from getting
sober sooner I don't know
um but that's a big reason why I feel so
strongly about talking about this kind
of stuff and why I wanted to you know
make your experience a larger focus of
this conversation yeah it's uh sort of
interesting to think about the just
talking about this stuff instill
publicly at least feels strange but I
but I I really I think it's really
important I have no regrets that I've
written I think people are going to
really respond to it Peter
um and I I you know I think it's a great
service to
um you know let people know that that
you know this was your experience and
you were able to get to the other side
of it it's empowering and I think
because I think you know a lot of people
the people look up to you they respect
you they Revere you
um and for you to say hey I'm a human
being and I had this experience and this
is what happened as a cautionary tale
but also as an exercise in male
vulnerability to model that I think is
is you know is is courageous and
important and also you mentioned you
know your kids and how important
um that was in in your realization and
in your recovery program and this idea
of how we pass our our you know
behaviors and our traumas down the line
is is so important because I think the
addict sort of thinks well I'm doing
this but I'm not hurting anyone or this
is my problem or Leave Me Alone
um but the pathology is much broader
than that and and you know Terry's quote
in the book was the one that was of
everything like I think the most
powerful so I wrote it down I'm gonna
I'm gonna recite it he says to you
family pathology rolls from generation
to generation like a fire in the woods
taking down everything in its path until
one person in one generation
has the courage to turn and face the
Flames that person brings peace to his
ancestors and Spares the children that
follow and this idea that you wanted to
be that guy like I want to be that guy
too you know
I I think
um
for as difficult as this Journey's been
and it will be by the way this is the
most difficult journey I will face the
rest of my life I don't
think first
you know for his
as small a fraction of the book as this
represents
from an effort perspective I probably
put more effort into this than even my
exercise
but that's the motivation
and even
it's also a bit of you know just
I got I got a lot to make up for you
know I I think I'm really lucky that my
wife is still with me frankly
um I don't think any other woman would
have put up with me
um
and so
I owe them
the best version yeah
well thank you for that
um it feels weird to like kind of you
know switch gears you know at this point
but
you know having explored that with you
and this being a chapter in your book
and the importance of of this in terms
of not not just how long we live but how
well we live like you know what are the
medicine 3.0 changes that we should be
thinking about and what can individuals
who read your book or or who are
listening or watching this what can they
start to do to you know tend to this
aspect this important aspect of our
well-being that's a great question
um
I think the first thing is just
you know
I talk about this briefly but
it's pretty unusual for someone who's
out of shape to not know they're out of
shape
right you know if you if you're having a
hard time walking up a hill
if you're having a hard time climbing
stairs if it if it hurts when you get
out of bed in the morning
it's hard to not know that
it's really easy
to be emotionally broken and not fully
appreciated or or more to the point to
be like me and be in total denial
I think the single most important thing
a person has to do here is
if for no other reason and to no one
other than themselves
start asking questions
like
are you
are you living in a way where your
relationships with other people are
healthy
what what was modeled to you what what
did you see and if you go back and
reflect on that
do you think that that represents the
best version of how you know people can
interact
um
there are lots of tests people can take
for example you're probably familiar
with the adverse childhood event score
the a score this is something that's
readily available online I do recommend
people take it right if you're if you're
sort of sitting there thinking like I
don't know what trauma is
well this is a checklist of 10 things
some of which are really obvious like
you're raped that's drama
um but your parents going through a
divorce when you're a kid is trauma
right
um
so you know when you kind of go through
an inventory like that it at least gives
you some sense of vulnerability
I think that
we talk about this a little bit that
it's a little harder for men to do this
but
whether you're male or female I think
you've
got to ask yourself the question do you
have someone you can really confide in
you have a friend that you could tell
anything to you know or what there's a
test for it they call it do you have
someone you could call in the middle of
the night if something was wrong
if you can't answer yes to that question
[Music]
I wonder why right is it because you
don't feel comfortable that you can
share that or is it because
you really don't have that person in
your life
I I think everybody benefits from
Psychotherapy and I don't think it's
very sexy what's very sexy today what's
very in Vogue today is like psychedelics
right like you know all you need is
a trip to Peru with a shaman and
everything's going to be fixed
and I talk very briefly about this in
the book but I've had most of these
experiences
and
some of them have actually been very
positive
but they aren't the healing process they
are just disruptive right they just
disrupt your psyche enough that they
make you open to the change
the change has to come from finding a
therapist in my view
who you are comfortable enough to be
able to speak with and I think it's
rather agnostic to the specialty or
discipline
um
the important thing is that you are
engaging with some modality
from a place of openness and honesty
yeah and it's just as we would say look
you gotta go get a blood test you got to
go get this test done you got to go do
these certain things like you should
know your VO2 max you should know your
you know your bone mineral density you
should have a dexa scan
I think we should take the same approach
here which is you should be able to have
someone that you emotionally check in
with and someone who can ask you
questions and get you thinking and
provoke you a little bit and figure out
what your state of emotional health is
this must really [__] with your
engineer's mind though right because
it's not it's not a math problem it's so
messy and non-linear
yeah so in our practice Rich we have
this thing called the longevity risk
assessment the lra
it's how we anchor our thinking about
every patient
so we believe that there are a discrete
number of things that are a threat to
your lifespan and health span so in no
particular order
cardiovascular disease
cancer
neurodegenerative disease
Falls later in life Automotive deaf
Orthopedic injury
and destruction disruption of emotional
health those are basically the big seven
so
you can see that each of those can
interfere with lifespan or health span
right
for each of those things we have inputs
so how do we make a diagnosis to
establish risk because our first goal is
to rank order those seven to understand
how to prioritize effort
so
25 things that go into the model right
so what's your family history what are
your Labs what's your you know VO2 max
as you can imagine the hardest thing to
get inputs for is the emotional health
piece
when I and and then there's outputs that
come out of this so based on how you
rank them that determines what your
behavioral changes are going to be
when I do this exercise for myself
what do you think is my rank order
remember my family history is Rife with
cardiovascular disease what do you think
is number one for me the greatest threat
to my longevity your emotional health
yeah it's number one on my list
um
I think I have emotional health number
one I think I have cancer number two I
think I have at this age
um probably Automotive death being
number three you know I kind of by the
way atherosclerosis is like number seven
for me right now because even though my
family history risk is so high
we've basically engineered that problem
almost to nothing
um
and yet you're right boy do we struggle
with coming up for the inputs because
only if a patient is willing to be this
vulnerable can we truly understand right
what their sense of purpose is what
their the state of their relationships
are
where they find Joy fulfillment
happiness all these things and I'll be
honest with like half my patients never
want to talk about that stuff it's just
maybe three quarters of my patients have
no desire to get into that and that's
okay you know maybe they will one day or
maybe they do with somebody else
It's gotta be well let me ask this as a
question is do you find that that is
more the case with your male patients
than with your female patients
I don't think I have a large enough
sample size to answer that but I will
say this
it's it's true for both I I don't I
don't know I'd have to really think
about the proportionality of it
um
but there is an epidemic of misery
I mean that it is you know the the the
the loneliness statistics seem to be
creeping up pretty rapidly
and uh you know the long-term
implications of that and you know coming
out of of covid and and how that
fractured a lot of relationships or or
just sort of made us more accustomed to
being cloistered in our homes and and
you know not with people like what does
that look like played out over a number
of years
I'm amazed at
because I see it in myself so maybe I'm
more attuned to see it in others but
um
the number of people who
are so willing to work so hard
at the expense of
personal relationships and again I say
that not in an accusatory term like I
say it as someone who does it
um
and I always worry like I just have to
remind myself that you know one day this
none of this stuff is going to matter
you know I talk a little bit about a
book that David Brooks wrote called the
road to character it was a very
important book for me to read during
this journey I read it really when I was
in the middle of hell
and
you know it was one of those things like
there's no one thing that changed for me
right it was an accumulation of things
but
his framing of thinking of your life via
its resume virtues versus your eulogy
virtues
is something I still remind myself of
every single day yeah uh and and related
to that is our guy Arthur Brooks yes of
course he talks about uh real friends
and deal friends right and and you know
the crisis that's visited upon many a
successful person when they realize all
of that success and the drive that led
to that has perhaps created more damage
than value and trying to put the pieces
together and and find a sense of
wholeness with oneself and one's
relationships untethered to external
validation or everything that went into
you know accomplishing all of these
things that
you know we we deluded ourselves into
thinking we're going to make us happy
yeah that's a tough I have a real soft
spot in my heart for people who have
achieved
super stardom
and I've been privileged enough as a as
you have to meet a number of these folks
and
um
I think it's hard I I then again I'm
sure nobody's sitting here feeling sorry
for someone who's you know famous and
Rich but
with it comes a real sense of
uh isolation and who's real and who
really cares about me and who doesn't
and who's using me and who has another
agenda
and
I
I think one needs to be thoughtful
before they decide they want to be a
public figure yeah I think that I think
that's probably very true right
um
on the on the subject of uh you you
mentioned
um
uh hallucinogens there was another quote
in the book uh that I wrote down
uh where you say too often I see people
tethering their hopes of transformation
solely to a ketamine trip or a journey
to the jungles of Peru with a shaman to
guide them through the mind-blowing
experience of an Ayahuasca Journey or
some other singular experience
or even as in my case thinking that two
weeks in a facility such as the bridge
is enough after which we can continue as
though nothing fundamental has changed
and I think that that this goes to it's
not unrelated to the narrative around
Health span extension it's this it's
this Allure of the quick fix or if I
just do this one thing all will be well
and I can maintain my operating system
yeah it's sort of like imagine you've
never exercised in your life okay so
you're you're a 50 year old who's never
exercised by the way a lot of people
like you right
the trip to the bridge where the
Ayahuasca Journey might be the thing you
need to realize
holy [__] you need to exercise
but guess what
now you have to exercise right so
I don't want to say like these things
are good or these things are bad but my
point is
in my experience
this emotional health thing
is a journey that is rooted in Daily
practice
and some days are good and some days
suck meaning some days I fail so badly
and I feel so ashamed
and I feel horrible
that I was a dick to my assistant
but one thing I learned that's so
important
is
I can't remember if it was I think it
was Esther who told me this and she of
course she's so eloquent she said it so
much better than this
she said Peter it's not about how many
times you screw up at this point
it's making sure you make it right
you know when she was talking about it
through the lens of my kids like if you
you're gonna get mad one day and you're
gonna yell at your kids again
and they might think it's Daddy of old
right but it's like no no the difference
is you make it right right away it's the
it's the healing that fixes it
and and I'll give you a really silly
example like on the weekend
my
um my boys were running around playing
around and our youngest is you know he's
kind of going through that phase he's
five and he's he's just not listening to
anything right so and one of the things
he keeps doing is he keeps running
around smacking everybody in the butt
like this is his favorite thing to do is
he'll walk up and smack you in the butt
as hard as he can 100 times and you're
like Airy enough enough enough enough
and finally after like the 10th time out
I just screamed him I'm like Harry get
in your room
and he just like you know
ran into his room
and I was immediately I felt full of
Shame
you just scared this kid you're like
and I went into my office and I started
to work
and I was like
I have to go and fix this right now I
have to let him know that I'm angry at
you because that's not what you're
supposed to do but I shouldn't have
yelled at you that much
and I go in his room
and it was just such a sad
awful reminder of what a childhood feel
what a child feels like in shame he
wouldn't look at me he was on his bed
head down and I kept saying Arie listen
I want to talk with you buddy I want to
talk with you about what just happened
it's like 10 minutes later
he wouldn't look at me and I said Arie
listen
Daddy's really upset that you're walking
around smacking everybody in the butt
but I shouldn't have yelled at you like
that I'm really sorry can I can we hug
and he wouldn't you know this was like
an hour he was really he wouldn't come
out of his room for an hour
so
I think in the olden days I would have
just beat myself up over that for so
long and I would have Contin I would
have actually taken it out on him more
paradoxically
but instead within an hour everything
was fine and we kept talking about it
and I was like look Airy you know why we
don't want you doing this you can't do
it at school you can't like you know
it's not like we're not going to
discipline you but I'm going to make
sure that I'm not blowing up at you
because I'm frustrated
that's a silly little example but it it
it's the that's the interstitial fluid
of what this stuff is about it's making
mistakes fixing mistakes as opposed to
beating yourself up and making bigger
mistakes
yeah a couple insights on that I mean
that it's it's about the half-life right
so the the the the period in between the
the negative action and the amends or or
you know kind of you know reaching
returning to some level of equilibrium
shrinks just like in meditation you get
that little extra gap of time to choose
how to respond rather than to just
impulsively react
super important and the more you
practice that you get better at it early
in recovery
a a guy that I know uh shout out to my
boy Scotty said uh if you're gonna eat
crow eat it hot right so it's like
you're gonna [__] up like just just deal
with it right away the faster you deal
with it my instinct is to like pretend
it never happened and deny it and of
course it just metastasizes and gets
worse and worse and worse I think with
kids the other layer to that is making
sure
that you're not projecting
your [__] onto them like you think
like oh I I need to make this right I'm
going to go to my kid I'm going to make
the amends and apologize but you're kind
of vomiting your own [__] onto them
and it's not for them to take on your
dysfunction like oh I'm so sorry and
this is my thing it's like that's just
actually making it worse and so for me a
lot of a lot of the you know the the the
work is around like maintaining my
container so I'm not you know pouring
out all of all of that kind of nonsense
and and putting it on the kid and I'll
do it without even being aware that I'm
doing it but give me an example
um I think that we often try to parent
in opposition to the dysfunction of our
own parents right so I grew up in a
household in which my mother was very
afraid of everything like extremely
fearful and worrisome and would kind of
vomit that onto me which then made me a
very risk-averse person or thinking the
world is threatening and dangerous of
course I don't want to do that to my
child but then I'll catch myself like
well we're just worried about you or
like I just you know I care so much
about you and I don't want you this but
and it's like I'm doing it I'm
perpetuating this pattern I'm doing the
very thing but I promised I would never
do and I've convinced myself that I'm
doing it out of concern for this person
but that's not really what it is
it's some kind of weird programming
interesting that's built in that uh that
I'm that I'm you know unless I'm mindful
I will just
default to
I mean
it speaks to this point it says lifelong
journey yeah
um
and I wish that it were easier right
like I wish that there were biomarkers
that I could follow for this the way I
can follow biomarkers are you crazy
well I mean you can't get in a simulator
yeah so the simulator is life yeah we're
in the simulator
right
um we've gone almost two hours we
haven't said anything about exercise or
nutrition I'm sitting here in the back
of my mind as I'm listening to you talk
like debating like do we even do that
now like
I think people will kill me if we don't
spend at least a couple minutes then we
talk about exercise a lot in the first
podcast we did we talked about we did a
lot on zone two and on
um on on VO2 max the importance of you
have a whole chapter in here on the
various modalities of exercise we're
told to exercise but what does that
actually mean here are the pillars that
you need to be building
um in parallel strength endurance of
course and you explain all these things
um stability yeah exercise is probably
the biggest section of the book it's
three chapters so there's more there's
more you know more more air time is
devoted to exercise than anything else
in this book what's interesting about
that and like yes I don't want to I
don't want to like go over stuff we've
already gone over but there's two things
that I'm curious about the first is
there is this adage that
you can't uh exercise your way out of a
bad diet
so that leads me to believe that
actually nutrition is more important
than exercise your thesis is that
exercise is by far the most important I
think that added stems from the if
you're purely thinking about it from a
weight perspective right
um so if you're if you're thinking about
it as is exercise the best tool we have
for weight management the answer is no
nutrition is the inputs matter more than
the outputs on weight management due to
the adaptations that come from energy
expenditure in other words if you take a
person who's you know going to ramp up
their energy expenditure by a thousand
kilocalories a day they're going to
accommodate by eating more as well so if
it's a weight management problem yeah
you can't really exercise your way out
of it but I would say sorry I know
you're in the middle of sharing an
additional thought but just to interject
here quickly uh
what what comes up for me
in thinking about heart disease and
neurodegenerative disease both both of
which are diseases of of the circulatory
system and given my family history yes
uh
I've been thinking more mindfully about
my nutrition and its relationship to you
know two of these at least two of these
you know four horsemen and yet you know
back in the month back in the you know a
little tickle in the back of my mind is
yeah but if I'm if if I just I can out
train this like you know I can it's okay
if I eat some of these Foods I wouldn't
ordinarily eat because I'm just burning
so many calories
you know you alluded to this just
briefly uh a while ago which was the
science around nutrition is like the
murkiest of all the signs if I
think about okay we just talked about
how squishy emotional health is so let's
put that aside for a moment but if you
want to talk about
pharmacology
sleep exercise
nothing is more murky than nutrition
I don't need to explain why I write
about it at length so let's just pause
it that that's a correct statement yes
that there is no field of human health
which the data are more ambiguous
I I was half tempted the editor would
not let me do this I was half tempted to
make the Nutrition chapter instead of
being two chapters that probably total
80 pages to make it one page which is
this is all we know about nutrition
if you want it to be black and white
this is all we know
which is
don't eat too much don't eat too little
there are certain micronutrients you
need to have
avoid things like E coli like it's
there's like 10 things that I can tell
you with absolute certainty
and obviously nobody would care to read
that
so of course I expanded on all of that
as it comes as it pertains to nutrition
I've
I've really changed my tune over the
last
12 to 14 years
and where I stand today is not where I
stood you know a decade ago not at all
today I believe that energy balance is
the single most important driver of ill
health as it pertains to nutrition
I think that there are lots of different
ways to regulate energy balance and
there are lots of third and fourth and
fifth order terms and I write about
those in detail
what types of fats are more healthy how
much protein animal versus plant protein
all of those things
but at the end of the day
it's really my conviction and I you know
this if there's one chapter that I
shared with more people
as experts to get input before I
finished putting pen to paper it was
this chapter
um because I wanted people who kind of
had different points of view from me and
what do you think about this what do you
think about that
um
and what I've distilled down is
energy balance matters and matters the
most so
that's an input equation not an output
equation so we exercise not to burn
calories we input we we exercise for the
structural and metabolic benefits but
not the energy expenditure benefits per
se
on the input side
to to regulate input you basically have
three levers that you pull
you can either and again this is not
something our ancestors had to think of
because food was relatively sparse but
in our environment today most of us need
to think about regulating
um certainly I do there's no chance I
can walk around eating as much as I want
whenever I want in whatever quantity 100
nourishment is a is is not the the low
hanging fruit problem here that's right
I do have some undernourished patients
but
80 to 90 percent of people are dealing
with you know being a little bit
overnourished
so our strategies are you can calorie
restrict
we so we can literally just say
independent of when I eat or what I eat
I will eat less
you can do dietary restriction which
means I will restrict elements within
the diet
or we can time restrict I will restrict
when I eat
um
each of those has its pros and cons
But ultimately they're in service of the
same thing which is consuming less
now once you make the decision of which
of those paths you go down and they can
be mixed and matched right like you can
say well I'm gonna be on a plant
plant-based diet or keto diet and I'm
also going to only eat between 8 AM and
2 p.m like again these things are
totally mixable
then the question becomes okay there's
four macronutrients carbohydrates
fats proteins and alcohol
how much do you emphasize each one
I start with alcohol because it's the
easiest it technically serves no purpose
in our diet so it's a
it's a nice hedonic pleasure
but I deconstruct the data and make the
case that there is no dose at which it
is healthy despite what some of the
really bad epidemiology tells you which
is that there's a reverse J curve and
technically like one to two drinks a day
is really healthy and abstainers have
the you know have a slightly higher risk
of mortality that's not true at all
so zero alcohol is the best probably up
to one drink a day has minimal effect
but after that it starts to actually
climb up
there's lots of other reasons to avoid
alcohol by the way
um especially if you're in the business
of trying to lose weight because alcohol
is itself a very oxidizable fuel so it's
the body's going to preferentially
oxidize ethanol before it oxidizes
everything else so you don't really want
to turn off fat oxidation if you're
trying to lose weight or postpone it or
delay it or move it down the queue you
want to keep it front and center
so it's just an unnecessary calorie
burning and sleep dysregulation
absolutely also if you're anything like
me anytime I drink I want to eat more so
it's it becomes this counterproductive
thing so just look I'm not going to sit
here and say don't drink I do but unders
again it comes down to risk understand
the risk is it worth it
um
you know I refuse to drink anything that
isn't exceptional so if someone serves
me a glass of wine and it doesn't taste
amazing I'm not going to drink it I'm a
snob in that regard it has to be good if
I'm going to take the risk
when it comes to the next three
macronutrients protein is where I place
most of my emphasis this is the one
where I really want to make sure my
patients are getting one gram per pound
of body weight
and the reason for that is that the
maintenance and preservation of lean
muscle mass is such an important part of
living long and living well
sarcopenia is such an underappreciated
cause of quality of life reduction
meaning loss of lean mass and strength
but how much of of that is the result of
of lack of proper exercise versus
protein intake like I I know you you
know you you have this perspective on
protein but are people walking around
not eating enough protein like it's hard
for me to imagine that that's truly the
case and I understand especially as you
age in these later decades
that it's important to make sure that
you're getting enough protein and you're
doing the kind of exercise you need to
maintain and build lean you know muscle
mass
very hard to maintain lean muscle mass
once you're our age
we become anabolically resistant as we
get older so
what a 20 year old can get away with
paradoxically is less than than I can
and that's going to be less than what I
can get away with when I'm you know 70
and 80 years old and that's really the
game I'm playing I'm playing a long game
so I'll give you an example
um if you look at some of the
epidemiology which we can discount
pretty quickly but even if you just take
the epidemiology on face value
it would suggest that for people under
50 eating less protein is associated
with lower mortality and for people over
50 eating more protein is associated
with lower mortality and on the surface
you sort of think well
I can see why when you're older you
might need more protein because of the
anabolic resistance and all these things
even if the difference in those
mortalities was identical in relative
rates you would still favor a high
protein strategy because of the absolute
difference in mortality in other words
your mortality is much higher when you
get older so even an equivalent relative
reduction in that risk would be a far
greater impact on actual mortality
but an added complexity to all of this
is is what that protein is packaged with
right protein you're not intaking
protein in isolation unless you're just
doing protein powders right so is that
protein coming in the form in something
that also has a lot of saturated fat Etc
what are the considerations that come
into play with that versus plant-based
proteins absorption issues ETC like it
starts to you know the the the you know
it starts to the the complexity of it
yeah pretty quickly so so those are two
different things which we'll talk about
so
um we'll start with the bioavailability
so animal protein is simply more
bioavailable than plant protein that
generally has to do with the fiber
that's associated with plant protein
that's an easy problem to overcome
there's two ways to overcome it the
first is you cook the plant right so
when you when you liberate that fiber
you make the plant protein you make the
plant protein more bioavailable
you can also just consume more of it so
you can do this in a really technical
way using you know Die Cast scores and
things like that which I don't recommend
for my patients who are plant-based we
typically tell them how many grams of
the most important amino acids they need
to eat in a day
so we're basically saying you need this
much leucine need this much lysine you
need this much methionine
you're going to have to eat more protein
to get them because you don't get you
know if you're not eating an egg it's
going to be harder to get like you can
get a gram of methionine in the single
egg but if you're not eating an egg
you're going to have to go around the
block to get it
so instead of saying look just fixate on
a total amount of protein that seems a
bit abstract it's getting them to
understand how this food has this much
leucine lysine and methionine and
focusing on that and again so now you're
focusing on the important amino acids
as far as the fats that they're packaged
with I think of everything I write about
in this book
there is no area
in where I was
more frustrated to not have a more
definitive point of view than on the
relationship
between saturated fat monounsaturated
fat and polyunsaturated fat when it
comes to human health
virtually all of the data on this
subject matter pertains to
cardiovascular disease
and I spared no expense at turning over
every stone and looking at this
and it became literally one of the most
unsatisfactory things I've ever done in
my life in terms of how uninteresting
the results were
basically the summary is this
and this is where I kind of end out
myself is
the safest thing appears to be
monounsaturated fats right so if you're
going to do it on the basis of the Leon
heart study and the predimed study
which are really the two best studies we
have I mean the predomed study is hands
down the best nutrition study we have in
the history of our species
it makes a pretty compelling case that a
diet high in monounsaturated fat is at
least superior to the other diets that
were tested
the epidemiology seems to validate that
the next question then becomes
and I would have assumed the data would
have been very strong in favor of
polyunsaturated fat ahead of saturated
fat but as you know
you have all these different camps and
tribes you have this one group of people
who say polyunsaturated fats are
horrible because seed oils are the devil
and
is really hard to find compelling data
to make that case
if you look at the most relevant most
extensive Cochrane collaborations
which are these are meta-analyzes that
are hundreds of pages long and I've gone
through these
You could argue that there is a slight
benefit to displacement of saturated fat
with polyunsaturated fat when it comes
to reducing the risk of heart disease
but my view on this problem is it's a
bit of a major in the minor and minor in
the major
because most of that downside of
saturated fat seems to be transmitted
through its effect on lipids so there's
no denying that a diet high in saturated
fat for many people will raise
atherogenic lipids
I have stopped trying to fight this
problem because for most people we can
control it so easy with pharmacology
that what I say is I want you to come up
with the diet that is going to be the
best for your other things that I have a
much harder time controlling
pharmacologically your energy balance
your in your insulin sensitivity and
your inflammation
I can measure all of those things by the
way they're just very hard to control
with a drug so I want to control those
with your nutrition
and if that means you can only fix that
with a diet that has a little too much
saturated fat in it and it's driving up
your APO B that's okay because that's
the one thing I actually can control
really well and for other patients
that's a diet that's really low in fat
or that's a diet that has very little
saturated fat
um
for the past six months for the first
time in my life actually I've never done
this before I've been tracking
everything I eat
just out of curiosity just to see like
because I'm not really trying to
restrict anything so the only effort I'm
making is getting my 180 grams of
protein a day everything else is just
I'm like kind of curious like how much
fat am I eating how much carbs am I
eating
um I have a weird diet like I'm equal
fat and carb
and high protein so I think I'm working
out to be about
uh I'm like probably 35 percent carb 35
protein 30 sorry 35 carb 35 fat 30
protein totally weird yeah that is weird
totally weird I think you say in the
book that for whatever reason you seem
to have a high tolerance in your ability
to eat saturated fat without any kind of
Downstream yeah when I was on a
ketogenic diet which I was for three
years I was on a ketogenic diet from
2011 to 2014.
there are a couple of you know
confounding factors I was also training
like crazy I mean this was sort of peak
adult
training performance for me I was
averaging at least three hours a day of
really serious training
but I mean I was getting 80 80 to 85 of
my calories from fat and probably half
of that was saturated
and my lipids were not out of whack at
all I mean I was I mean you you look at
any biomarker of me in that era I mean
my triglycerides were in the 30s my HDL
cholesterol was high LDL cholesterol was
modest I mean it was below the 20th
percentile that has to be unusual though
like it is I could not do that no I
couldn't come anywhere near that I'm
healthy yeah I don't I don't I don't
know why it happened in me I've seen a
few other people for whom it works as
well but I think it's the exception and
not the rule
and I've also had some patients who
they've gone on ketogenic diets
everything has gone well
except their their cholesterol goes
through the roof they look like they
have familial hypercholesterolemia and I
say well we got two choices because I
don't like this
either we drug it
or we try an experiment which is if you
really feel hell-bent on being in this
ketogenic diet would you be willing to
totally change your fat composition
and in the cases where patients have
said I really want to stay on the diet
and I don't want to be on a drug yet
um let's go all monounsaturated and
higher polyunsaturated and really cut
down the saturated to like 25 grams a
day
and in some cases not all cases in some
cases about half the time it fixes it um
so saturated fat I think drives
athrogenic particles by driving up the
synthesis of cholesterol itself
but also by impairing the liver and more
importantly I think by impairing the
liver's clearance of cholesterol
so it's a tricky molecule
it gets complicated my brain wants to
make it simple ldlc high no good APO B
you know not in range bad you know like
these are things that you know need to
be addressed immediately uh then I'm on
my phone and I'm scrolling through
Instagram and people are are you know
literally you know peeling a stick of of
butter and taking a bite out of it and
then you know and then eating their
their steak for breakfast and talking
about how everything you you've been
taught about LDL cholesterol dietary
cholesterol all of that is nonsense this
is you know the way that we should be
eating and and there's a lot of people
who are very uh influenced by a number
of people who are who are advocating for
this way of eating so you know care to
comment yeah it's it's very
disappointing for me to see that kind of
stuff
um
I
I try to stay as far away from the diet
Wars as possible yeah and this this book
is the furthest thing from anything
tribal like you know you really have in
a culture in which
there's a sense that if you if you want
to make an impact uh you have to you
have to be you know somewhat extreme or
have some kind of contrarian perspective
everything that you do is lives outside
of that you know it's it's all very
grounded but sorry I interrupted you
again no I just um look I've seen I've
had patients show up to my practice that
are on you know incredibly extreme diets
and
I just you know I take it as my you know
first of all I feel like I've got the
time to work with somebody so I don't
have to solve this problem on day one
right so if somebody shows up and
they're on like the carnivore diet and
they're eating steak three meals a day
and
putting butter in their coffee or
whatever I don't know if that would be a
carnivore diet but whatever
and their Labs look horrible I say well
all right let's talk about this diet
like what's what is it doing well for
you why do you like it oh well I feel
great I've lost all this weight I said
great okay let's talk about why those
things might be happening and what are
you not getting from this diet
so then they'll say well
you know plants are toxic
and I say okay let's let's think about
that for a minute right let's go down
the like is there any data to support
that right and
um
look if you get somebody who's
intellectually honest
you might say well look I don't dispute
that you might feel better having gone
from eating a standard American diet
which had a lot of stuff in it to being
on this highly restrictive diet
the question is you took 57 things out
of your diet and you feel better
how do you know which of the 57 things
it was
don't you think we ought to go back and
try to do this in a slightly more
thoughtful way
because I would say we don't really have
any evidence that the diet you're on now
is sustainable it might be
again this gets to kind of risk and
uncertainty like it's possible that
humans can live on that diet and be
perfectly healthy it's just improbable
and when people have their blood worked
on and they see these elevated markers
and are told not to be concerned about
that
that feels you know you
I probably devote more air time to
trying to dispel those myths and I
actually did a recent AMA just on that
topic which was
on again the causality of APO B this is
such an important concept I mean it's
come up now three times because it
matters
if something is causal
then anything that increases it has to
be viewed as problematic
here's what's not causal HDL cholesterol
is not causal
a lot of people justify their elevated
LDL cholesterol or apob
by the fact that
their HDL cholesterol also goes up and
their triglycerides go down
and so they say well look we know that
high HDL cholesterol and low
triglycerides are associated with lower
risk of heart disease
so who cares if my LDL cholesterol is
high
well here's the problem
when you look at both the clinical trial
data and the mendelian randomization
data they're all in the same direction
the mendelian randomization data I can
explain in a moment what that means if
people want to understand
make it abundantly clear
that high HDL cholesterol
not causally associated with a lower
risk of heart disease and low HDL
cholesterol is not causally related to a
higher risk of cardiovascular disease
therefore
it doesn't matter if they're higher or
lower they're not causal conversely
when you look at LDL cholesterol and you
look at all of The Medallion
randomizations and all of the clinical
trial data
it all moves in the same direction
higher LDL cholesterol is causally
related to more ascvd
so when someone says to me these two
biomarkers got better and this one got
worse I'm going to ignore this one and
pay attention to these two I say you're
ignoring the causal one in favor of the
two non-causal ones that's a bad
strategy
and and explain the difference between
ldlc and apob in terms of you know a
blood marker
that one should be paying attention to
how about I'll give a real quick on
cholesterol because I think it's
important to understand right so so our
body every cell in our body makes
cholesterol it's an essential molecule
for life so despite the fact that it's
sort of been demonized if you couldn't
make cholesterol in every cell in your
body you wouldn't have been born that's
how it would have been lethal in utero
um
so our body has to kind of solve a
problem which is it needs to move
cholesterol around the body but
cholesterol is fat
and we can't move fats around
in water and we use our circulatory
system which is water to move fat around
so we have to come up with a way to
package them in water-soluble things
these things are called lipoproteins
some of them have a high density some of
them are low density some of them are
intermediate or very low density so the
low density lipoprotein
called LDL happens to contain a lot of
cholesterol on its cholesterol and
triglyceride
the ldls are wrapped with a protein
called apolipoprotein B there's one and
only one apole lipoprotein B on every
LDL and there's also one on every other
atherogenic particle in its lineage
which is the IDL the vldl and the lp
little a
in this sense apob is the most important
biomarker we have with respect to lipid
burden
because by knowing the concentration of
apob you know the exact concentration of
the total number of atherogenic
particles
so it is a better predictor of
cardiovascular risk than LDL cholesterol
which is the more common test that is
developed which just looks at the amount
of cholesterol within the ldls so one is
saying how much cholesterol cargo do you
have in the LDL particle the other one
is saying how many total particles do
you have of not just LDL but the other
Bad actors I got you
um and and APO B is it's relatively it's
it's only relatively recently that it's
kind of come on the scene as as the
thing that people should be looking at
right like this is finally not for you
yeah yeah exactly medicine 2.0 sure sure
I mean Alan snyderman has been you know
screaming about this for three decades
um but believe it or not the U.S is the
last country to come around on this it's
been largely entrenched in the ldlc
Dogma but but you're right now it's
becoming more mainstream and we
encourage anybody to go out and say to
your doctor not only do I want my lipid
panel I want to see my LP little a and I
want to see my APO B
um what are some of the other tests that
should be requested in terms of scans I
mean we can start with with heart health
the calcium scan but there's like soft
plaque scans now and things other other
types yeah we prefer CT angiograms over
calcium scan so calcium scan is just a
quick CT scan of the heart with no
contrast and it will only show calcium
um but 15 of the time it'll miss it
it'll either Miss calcium or Miss soft
plaque so it's a CT angiogram which is
more expensive and has more radiation
but if Done Right still has
you know less than four or five percent
of your total annual allotment radiation
is a much better test
and
I think these serve a purpose but they
don't have to be done on everybody right
so they're they're helpful for people
who are on the fence about treatment
depending on their age so if you have a
young person who maybe has a higher
family history risk
but they're kind of ambivalent about
being treated maybe seeing that they
already have a finding on their CTA is
the thing that they need to move ahead
um conversely if you have a person who's
really old
and their numbers look really horrible
but they also don't want to be treated
seeing a completely normal scan at a
really Advanced age could also maybe
steer you off treating right if they're
resistant and and how it would seem to
me that these tests for heart health
would not be unrelated to to
understanding risk for neurodegenerative
disease as well right given that they
are diseases of the circular circulatory
system but otherwise testing other than
genetic testing there doesn't seem to be
a lot that you can do to predict these
or to see where you're at in terms of
the development of of those diseases
well when it comes to Parkinson's
disease and Lewy Body dementia
it's it's a little harder than with
Alzheimer's disease I think with
Alzheimer's disease the apoe genotype is
the dominant gene not the only one
there's at least 20 genes that are
playing a role in those diseases in in
ad specifically
but apoe is the dominant one and that's
an easy test to get
but it is important that people
understand what it says and what it
doesn't says right and what it doesn't
say so
apoe is not a causative Gene it's not a
deterministic gene it's a risk Gene so
fortunately only about one percent of
people who develop Alzheimer's disease
do throw do so through a causative
pathway where there's a deterministic
gene that guarantees they're going to
get the disease there's three genes I
won't bother naming that account for one
percent of Alzheimer's disease and if
you have one of those three genes
unfortunately you will get Alzheimer's
disease
um this is an awful set of genes and
they typically afflict people very early
in life so when you hear about someone
who got Alzheimer's disease in their 40s
or 50s it's almost assuredly the case I
write about this in some length
um I write about it not so much because
it's such a big problem but because it's
where the diagnosis and nomenclature
around Alzheimer's disease came from and
I believe it's part of the root cause of
why we have such a hard time
understanding the disease today
with uh with Chris Hemsworth and
Limitless there's that uh you know
amazing sequence where where you have to
tell him that he has this double marker
which creates this enhanced
um risk for Alzheimer's but that's I
mean what percentage of people have that
oh two percent one to two percent people
it's very rare and it was
you know pretty shocking when we got his
blood test back and I certainly wasn't
expecting that yeah I mean how did how
did that go and like how has he changed
some of his lifestyle habits as a result
of that news
well when I so the whole plan for that
was we did a blood test when Chris was
in LA it was like the end of 2019 and we
were going to start shooting in January
2020 in Australia
and the plan was I'd get the results
back but I would never talk about it
with him until we were on camera
um
that's fine I get it but then I got the
results back and I saw that he had the
E4 E4 combo
and I sort of thought about it for a day
and I was like yeah there's just no way
like it this is a hard discussion to
have with a person
under any circumstance because the
moment you start talking
they're only picking up
a fraction of what you're saying once
they hear Alzheimer's disease risk
higher
do you really think that they're going
to pick up on the Nuance of it's not
deterministic and we have things that we
can do to mitigate risk and there's
other genes that can offset this like no
chance and I know this from experience
I've had this discussion so many times
it never it's like that see in that
scene in the movie Contagion where Matt
Damon's being told that his wife is and
he doesn't hear any of it yeah
so I called Darren Aronofsky who's the
director and I said um hey I know that
you guys wanted to do it a certain way
but I got to talk to Chris about
something and I can't tell you what it
is because it's not your you know this
is his between him and I
um so you got to take a leap of faith on
this and decide that it's okay for me to
kind of break this one part of the the
filming and do it so so Darren just had
Chris call me directly and and we sort
of facetimed he was sitting there in
Australia with his wife you know hanging
out and
I just had that discussion with him and
I think he was kind of like
okay so what does this mean
explain it okay okay
all right so what does it mean which is
again the totally normal response
and then we didn't talk about we didn't
talk about it again until filming which
was probably like three weeks later
and then of course after that we got and
I don't remember what that's like but I
haven't even seen that episode so I
don't remember anything of how it
happened that's been over three years
um
but then since that time
it's become you know a much bigger you
know now he really understands it right
like now he's he's dug in deep and he
understands okay
my risk is going up this amount
um you know we've we've done a bunch of
other things to look and you know done
some scans and and made sure that yeah
everything looks perfect right now
um but now you know
your highest priority
from the standpoint of your longevity is
probably going to be taking a bunch of
steps to delay this thing as long as
possible or frankly eliminate it and by
the way there are lots of people with
APO E4 genes who do not get Alzheimer's
disease
yeah it's heavy you talk in the book
about another your one of your patients
uh a woman who in the similar situation
you know is on the receiving end of that
news but you know having
25 years to work on this you know in
advance of perhaps any symptoms showing
up whatsoever and that's really the Crux
of where you're you know your focus as a
as a practitioner is like how do we use
these intervening years with this
understanding or this indicia that
something might be happening to divert
it
I think that's where there's a really
big divide also between medicine 2.0 and
Medicine 3.0 and there's probably no
greater example of that than Alzheimer's
disease
I think it's very difficult for medicine
2.0 to acknowledge that this is a
disease for which prevention
is an option
um and there was a lot of you know
Darren Aronofsky after Limitless came
out forwarded me some text that he got
from some angry people like how
irresponsible of you to do this how dare
you like tell you know have Chris find
out that he has this Gene like you know
people were really pissed off not all of
them of course but some of them
and I you know Darren said what do you
think about this and I said look I'll
tell you what I think about it I said I
think that just demonstrates a person's
bias this is a person who obviously
you know believes that the best thing
you know let's just assume that this is
a good person first of all this is a
person who is in their best interest in
their in their best judgment believes
that nothing good comes of telling Chris
that news well let's dig into that
assumption if nothing good comes from
telling somebody that news by definition
you believe you can't do anything about
it
by definition you believe this is a fate
accompli
and I just said look I'll show you tons
of data that say that that's not the
case
I'll show you tons of data that say
how you eat how you exercise how you
sleep how you manage hearing loss how
you manage depression those things
are very related to the development of
dementia
so which is empowering because it gives
people agency and to do these things
irrespective of whether that person ends
up with Alzheimer's or not or any number
of other chronic ailments is in your
best interest to do anyway right like
all of these things are going to make
you healthier and happier you know
delay these chronic illnesses but even
in the event that you ultimately succumb
or whatever you're doing what's right
for yourself and and your long-term
Health well just as in the exercise
sections of the book I talk about in a
reserve right you want the highest VO2
max possible
so that you are starting at the highest
place when that decline kicks in right
you want the most muscle mass you want
the strongest body possible because
there's nobody that if anybody's coming
here to tell you you're not going to
decline like they're crazy like we're
all declining
so the goal is maximize your reserve
have as much water behind the dam as
possible so that when the drought comes
you can survive longer
well this applies to cognition as well
and
that's why I pretty much am doing every
single thing in the E4 E4 Playbook
myself
and I would encourage everybody to be
doing that in other words we should all
act like we're Chris
because whether you're E3 E2 or E4
you're not immune to this disease and
even if you don't get the disease or
even if you looked in the future and you
had a crystal ball and it says okay you
will not get Alzheimer's disease it
doesn't mean you won't cognitively
decline it we're all going to
cognitively decline right so what you
know why does sleep matter why does
exercise matter why does insulin
sensitivity matter
all of these things matter because
they're going to continue to preserve as
much cognitive horsepower as possible
for as long as possible independent of a
disease state
[Music]
we talked a lot last time about the
centenarian decathlon so I don't want to
repeat that but I did want to drill down
on one thing
which which seems to be like this this
thing that you're you've been hammering
a lot on on uh social media which is
grip strength like this is your this is
your jam right
what the [__] is up with grip strength
you know hanging from a bar or being
able to open a jar and all that why is
that a proxy
for the kind of strength that's
important to be working on and thinking
about as we age
so we really only have two ways that we
interact with the outside world right
most of us are not walking around
head-butting things
these guys and our feet
so anything about those things that are
not working perfectly leads to big
problems
um we'll save feet for another day
because that's a whole enormous problem
that works its way from feet to ankles
knees hips and back and the rest of it
when your grip strength suffers
it limits your ability to do pretty much
anything with your hands from opening a
door opening a jar pulling something all
of those things
um
so I mean just start with the data right
so if you look at the data and I include
a figure in the book about this right if
you look at the the strength of the
association between grip strength and
any disease all cause mortality I
include onset of dementia death from
dementia doesn't matter the stronger you
grip the longer you live
and
we can never do an experiment to see and
prove that that is causal
but what we can do is we can look
through the Austin Bradford Hill
criteria of epidemiology and check off
all the boxes that say boy most of those
things suggest that this Association has
causality built into it is it the grip
strength itself or is it the fact that
somebody with good grip strength is
probably doing lots of things for their
overall strength and well-being I think
it's more the latter than the former
yeah I think grip strength just happens
to become a very good proxy four because
if you have a strong grip by definition
you're strong here here you probably
have you know you probably have stable
scapula things like that it's also an
easier thing to measure
you know
it's we like that's why VO2 max
is such a strong association with
lifespan
it's not that it's the strongest thing
like there might be something out there
that's stronger that we haven't measured
maybe if we took the time to measure
lactate threshold we'd see that it's
even slightly better
it's just that it's very reproducible it
can be done across any lab any study and
it's been studied in millions and
millions of people and the same is true
with grip strength it's objective it's
easy to measure
but I think it as you said I think it's
a proxy for something bigger which is
it's an overall proxy for muscle mass
strength things like that and and is the
best way to develop grip strength
hanging from a bar no you're definitely
on Instagram or how do we that's it
that's a test set so I'll do those sets
to test
it's really carrying things it's by far
the best way so farmer carries
um again you know I Get Grip strength by
dead lifting and doing other things as
well but I don't these are things that
are all kind of secondary what everybody
should be doing is carrying
this is our this is the human superpower
right you know Michael Easter writes
about this in um the Comfort crisis I
think which is there's no animal
like we're pretty pathetic animals if
you think about it right like you know
everything can run faster than us over a
short period of time swim faster they're
pound for pound stronger all this other
stuff
a couple things we do really well over
24 hours we can cover pretty much more
territory than any other land animal
and we can carry far more weight upright
no one can no wait I'm Gonna Come Close
that's true I never thought about that
yeah yeah obviously a horse if you
domesticate it will carry more weight on
its back but yeah like it's not like a
gorilla can carry more weight upright
than we can like we were really but we
were more surprising I would think a
gorilla could not for a long distance no
they're they're not they don't have that
stability right like we can we can stand
up and just carry things so like it's
not a big ask for a guy our age to carry
his body weight in his hands yeah you
know half your body weight in each hand
and be able to carry that for minutes
yeah so farmer carries that's the main
thing yeah I mean that's it lit if you
did nothing else but that that would be
the most important thing and then of
course there's so many variations on
these things
there's a a billion threads I could pull
on exercise and nutrition with you where
we got to wrap this up at some point but
I I want to um
I don't want you to go without talking a
little bit about uh this notion of of
healthy addictions you just put up a
blog post the other day about this and
and this is something I've been thinking
a lot about as it pertains to my own
behavior and habits uh of course but
also more generally the way that we can
all
um
sort of hide behind healthy addictions
that Society you know Smiles upon or or
which as I said earlier you know make us
successful whether it's workaholism
exercise addiction
um which I'd like to hear your thoughts
on and also you know some of these
nutrition protocols with fastening
intermittent fasting
uh you know delayed eating all these
sorts of things are are ways to mask
Eating Disorders or extreme diets Etc uh
we can just say well I'm doing the
carnivore diet or I'm doing you know I'm
doing one meal a day or all it's like
actually you have an eating disorder
that's what's really going on here uh
you're just doing what's trendy right
now
um or you know whether it's training for
an Iron Man Endurance Sports of course
like all of these things if you're uh
you know prone to addictive behavior
like I am I can easily burrow into any
number of these things
um
and uh you know and and hide contentedly
for for quite some time and I've done
that
you know one of the things I think
that's really interesting to ask and I
ask myself all the time have you I'm
sure you've listened to it but I don't
know if you listen to it recently
you know the commencement speech by
David Foster Wallace this is water of
course one of my favorites so um
that was another thing I'll tell you
when I was really in the throes of early
recovery
I would probably listen to that once a
week
um I could almost recite It Off by heart
um and it really speaks to me and one of
the things that
um constantly sends chills
uh my spine is when he talks about how
we're all addicts right like
where and he words it through religion
we all have a God and he's you know he
talks about how some people their God is
the actual God
and he kind of alludes the fact that
they might be they might be the lucky
ones but if your God is power you're
never going to be powerful enough
if your God is intelligence you're
always going to feel like a failure or a
fraud
if your God is your body you will die a
thousand deaths before they actually
bury you
and
I think that that goes back to kind of a
question you asked earlier which is how
do you take stock of where your
emotional health is I'll tell people go
and listen to David Foster Wallace's
talk five times and go through it like
be honest and look in words when you
hear that like
where is your god
and don't say you don't have one right
like just because you're an atheist
doesn't mean you don't have a God and I
think about this all the time like I
think about
how much did I worship my body
and of course I still do to some extent
and I think about
how can I slowly start to let that go
where can I release this tension between
I place such a premium on my body
that I'm doing all of these things take
to take care of it but at the same time
I can't worship it so much that I'm
unwilling to Let It Go as it goes hmm
and I think that's like the biggest
challenge that I think I'm going to face
in the next 50 whatever how many years I
have left 30 40 years I don't know
um but
it's that it's the graceful aging part
that says like you got to let go
sometimes like
you know do the best you can
but don't do so much more that you ruin
this experience of living
and like you it's hard to imagine how
restrictive I used to be in my nutrition
it's insane
and in some ways like my nutrition today
is so unrestrictive
in some ways as a response to that
um it probably looks pretty regimented
to the ordinary person but sure I I eat
it I eat a pretty healthy diet compared
to the average American I'm sure but
it's it's I wouldn't if my kids make
brownies like I wouldn't hesitate to eat
three of them like I did like it's that
it I'm not restrictive in that way what
you're talking about involves
threading a needle and doing a bit of a
dance because on the one hand like you
you have this whole thing about the
centenarian decathlon I want to win this
like there's a drive there there's a
commitment there's maybe you know even a
little bit of an obsession and the
personal growth comes in
uh holding that Loosely you can have
something that you care about that
you're working towards but which you
also maintain some level of of healthy
distance from like that that ability to
be
um okay
with where you're at and who you are
while also working towards some type of
self-improvement
um is a is a you know it's it's a weird
kind of thing that you're trying to hold
right like it it is water that you're
trying to you know that's slipping
through your fingers
but I think the the key to the whole
thing
and I think you'll agree
is this is this piece about
self-love if you hold yourself in
healthy regard then you can be okay with
the natural progression of your own
decline a decline that you're trying to
slowly arrest and yet at some level
are also at peace with
I I agree that that's that's the
ultimate Challenge and if you if you
don't have that healthy self-regard then
you are going to be
driven in an unhealthy way to achieve
this other thing which you've convinced
yourself will solve that problem for you
yeah I I think that um
I guess that's one of the things that I
even hesitate to use the word longevity
sometimes because
the way I think of it you have to spend
a while explaining what it means and how
it includes all these other things like
you're talking about
whereas for the most part I think when
you hear the word longevity you think
immortality you think perfection
and truthfully the first version of this
book
that's what it was about uh so why the
book didn't come out yeah these things
happen when they're supposed to happen
yeah
and there's a there's a there's a
spirituality in that Peter right like
you you talk in the book a little bit
about
um what was the quote that you were
exposed to when you when you first
arrived oh yeah like religion is for
whoever Spirit religion is for people
who are afraid of hell spirituality is
for people who have been there right so
so my immediate question to that and
maybe we can end on this is what does
your spirituality look like like how has
that impacted you or this recovery
Journey that you've been on
um has that
um
has that uh you know LED you into a
place of Greater openness and and
receptivity to things perhaps a bit more
mystical
I wish I could say yes but but the truth
of it is no I think the biggest impact
it has had on me
which is probably some variation of
spirituality is that um
it's made me feel much less significant
in the universe
I don't think I I think it's so much
easier for me now
to appreciate my irrelevance on this
planet
and
that makes it easier for me to
focus on the things that matter
I
you know when my wife met me she used to
she made a t-shirt for me so just it's a
bit of a weird story but
in residency you know we worked really
hard we worked like 120 hours a week and
I still in residency despite doing this
was adamant that I like write this book
about surgery
and I would work on this thing with all
my free time and it took like years and
I it was basically it ended up being a
very small little book but
it I had to read
I forget like
19 Pages a day of surgical textbooks for
three years and then summarize and do it
and I'm working on this nonsense and my
wife was like why are you doing this and
she's like
was like well what's your legacy going
to be like you got to have a legacy in
this world and so one day she made me a
t-shirt that was like what's your legacy
or something it was kind of mocking me
and
I just think like
I think that's nonsense like I'm not
gonna have a legacy like if I died
tomorrow
outside of my wife and my kids everyone
will forget about me in three months
and I used to like that thought like to
fight against that used to be so much a
part of my existence
and I am so at peace with that now
that I think that's the closest thing I
can say to spirituality which is
um
I I was at um
Rick Rick Rubin has a beautiful place in
Italy we were there with him last summer
and it's a it's an old place like but
Rick is like the third person to own it
in
500 years
um and I I was so moved by this place
because I felt
like it was the most irrelevant I've
ever felt in a good way and I remember
thinking I would love to die here
and be buried there so that
the carbon nitrogen oxygen in me became
a part of that Vineyard uh-huh
and I don't know I just think that
that's to me that spirituality it's just
um it's not Mystic it's just
appreciating the carbon cycle and
knowing that we're all just kind of
doing the best we can and not much more
I think they're sort of uninspired no I
think there is something you know quite
beautiful and mystical built into that
there's of course this you know
appreciation for impermanence and and
and the humility that that provides
right and I think embodying that
uh you know sense of impermanence and
and and humility allows you to more
clearly see and understand and
appreciate the things that actually
matter in the present which are your
relationships Etc and it divorces you
from like the Legacy like that that
burning desire that's driving you when
that gets snuffed out or at least muted
somewhat you can then actually start
living your life and and stop running
away from it right like you say in the
epilogue of the book that basically this
drive to understand Health span and
Longevity was driven by this extreme
fear of death and a determination to
have a lasting Legacy is born out of an
unhealthy relationship with with death
right and coming to terms with that and
and making peace with that allows you to
actually
live your best life and ironically
extend your health benefit and lifespan
in so doing it right I believe so yeah
yeah
um beautiful Matt well
this is great uh
probably a little different than than
some of the other podcasts you're gonna
do I if you want the tactics probably
tune in to Tim Ferriss who knows what
you're going to do with with uh Andrew
huberman Rogan could go on any one of a
million directions I suppose but this
was really special for me and and I
appreciate you being so open and honest
today and like I said at the outset uh
the work that you do is really important
it's meaningful to me it's meaningful to
to millions of people and I commend you
on your commitment to it and actually
finally following through on this book
which is now going to be out in the
world in which you ended up voicing
yourself yes after some consternation
about your ability to read your own book
I'm really glad I did it yeah yeah good
I'm glad I didn't have to do it under
these circumstances but I'm really glad
I did it yeah good man well uh we
certainly didn't cover all of it we we
covered maybe .0001 of it so uh perhaps
I can control you to come back and talk
with me more I'd love to and you gotta
come out
spent some time in Austin with me as
well I would love to do that thank you
Peter
um let's get your get some tea and some
ice or whatever you need on your voice
but we did it three hours you made it
through power through that that's 74
that believed in you were correct cheers
thanks thanks peace
[Music]